[Musique]
raphaël
rossello euros bonjour nous vous
recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
interne et qui s'appelle think ur view
est ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement absolument rafale rossé
lourd donc banquier d'affaires de
l'économie réelle depuis 45 ans qu'est
ce que vous avez fait pendant 45 ans et
ses coupons qui dure et elle en
fait à l'intérieur de ce vaste domaine
de la banque vous avez un segment qui
s'appelle la banque d'affaires qui
est en fait la banque conseille et alors
que nous partageons rigoureusement la
même trousse à outils il y à vraiment
deux segments il
y à celui des entreprises dont
les besoins sont des besoins financiers
d'optimisation de leurs performances et
il ya le segment dont je m'occupe que
sont les petites et moyennes entreprises
ou ce que l'on appelle aujourd'hui les
entreprises de taille intermédiaire qui
sont très souvent des entreprises
patrimoniales appartenant à des aléas
des fondateurs ou à des héritiers de
fondateurs quel volume qui est le je
dirais que mon spectre
de d'intervention c'est des entreprises
qui vont de 500 personnes à 2000 2500
personnes à peu près et qui l on découpe
des bons
dirais-je des contraintes ou des
problématiques qui sont plus le
financement de leurs exploitations avec
bien sûr les mêmes problématiques
d'actionnariat de ratio entre la dette
et les fonds propres c'était alors
pourquoi l'économie réelle c'est que mes
grands confrères des grandes banques de
londres de wall street et quelques-unes
en europe bien entendu quand
je les observe puisque je les ai croisés
régulièrement pendant ces 45 ans ont des
réflexes qui touche à la politique qui
touche à la macroéconomie qui touche
au lobbying qui touchent à des outils
qui ne sont pas les miens les miens
c'est
c'est la problématique et
je vais en prendre un ou deux cas
concrets d'entreprises qui recherche
entre 5 et 20 millions de fonds propres
pour créer une activité qui va faire
entre 5 et 40 millions de business à
l'échéance de 42 2 4 ou 5 ans et ces
gens là n'ont pas tous ces artifices
artifices
n'est pas le mot n'ont pas tous ces
éléments collatéraux dans dans
l'instruction et la gestion du dossier
moi je suis vraiment sur le terrain et
de surcroît ça m'a permis de satisfaire
un désir que j'avais depuis toujours qui
est en fait de deux rencontres et tous
les intervenants beaucoup de mes clients
pourraient témoigner que je suis
probablement adhéra à descendre dans les
ateliers aller dans les bureaux regardez
ce qui est sur les tableaux d'affichage
vraiment
en position 1 qui alors par opposition à
ceux je veux dire quand vous êtes le
banquier conseil de quand vous êtes le
banquier conseil d'une
entreprise comme philips ou lvmh ou
nestlé etc il n'y a aucun intérêt à
descendre voir ce qui se passe dans les
ateliers d'autant plus que vos
intervenants vos points de contacts ne
sont pas eux-mêmes dans l'étagé au
dessus des ateliers ou des ou des
bureaux d'études donc
c c'est une vision qui est je parle de
mes grands confrères qui est décoré
les esquives a expliqué un certain
nombre de choses que je souhaite pouvoir
partager avec vous aujourd'hui parce
qu'il est légitime qu'il soit
effectivement dans
une perception un peu abstraite très
conceptualiser de la problématique ils
doivent adresser la mienne est très
complète c'est combien d'emplois
quelques elle quel va être le ratio
d'endettement est ce que je vais avoir
assez de cash pour payer les intérêts
qui me sont demandés fait je veux dire
on n'est pas on n'est pas dans
l'abstraction on ne peut pas être dans
l'abstraction donc oui je revendique ma
légitimité sur votre plateau aujourd'hui
c'est si je dois en avoir une c'est que
aux quatre coins du monde occidental
j'ai accompagné des gens qui avaient qui
était pas totalement à risque dans leur
société
c'était pas c'est s était pas d les
gérants d'un projet non non non il était
un risque leur patrimoine leur vie leur
famille au
nord absolument et d'ailleurs je suis le
fils d'un entrepreneur à scientifiques
et entrepreneurs j'ai été moi-même
entrepreneurs pendant cinq ans de ma vie
et j'ai un respect mais absolue pour ces
hommes et ces femmes qui voilà
qui pense pas qu'ils ne pensaient pas
être un des autres éléments qui ne
pensaient pas nécessairement à faire
fortune il pensait à répondre à une
fonction nécessairement
utile pour la société certes alors
avantage de terrain mais là un
des points de mon constat que je fais au
terme de ses 45 ans est de dire les
motivations un peu évolué ça reste
toujours le désir d'entreprendre bien
sûr puisqu'elle qu'est ce que vous
pensez de
ce concept qu'on appelle la start up née
shon est ce que c'est la bullshit n'est
sean est ce que c'est d'aider licorne
qui ne sont simplement que dresser aller
chercher des subventions publiques est
ce que réellement il ya des choses
viable dedans ou est-ce qu'on arrose un
peu tout ça cet écosystème dans l'espoir
de trouver quelque chose ou on fait
semblant de s'agiter on
commence déjà à rentrer dans le vif du
sujet
alors
d'abord
je ne suis pas un mot 2 je fais le
métier qui a été inventé dans la cité de
londres il ya 150 200 ans et j'applique
des préceptes de je dirais de de
compréhension de mes clients qui doit se
s'affranchir
des phénomènes de mode quand le mot de
start up née shell est un phénomène de
mode en
fait je ne comprends pas parce que la
notion de start up elle décrit le fait
que à l'issue de ses études un
ou plusieurs jeunes
diplômés ont la possibilité parce qu'ils
en ont le désir parce qu'ils jouent ils
vont rechercher une une récompense une
gratification peut être un peu plus
rapide que les générations d'avant ils
vont chercher dans le cadre de ce que
l'on appelle des start-up réponse
à ce désir mais en réalité dans ma
génération ou celle de mes parents
toutes les entreprises qui ont été
créées n'étaient pas des start up au
sens que ce n'était pas un jeune diplômé
qui crée à cabinet architecture ou une
société de pharmacie ou autre c'était
quelqu'un qui avait une expertise et une
expérience dans
un secteur et qui à l'âge n'ont pas de
25 mai de 35 ou 45 ans se mettait à son
compte donc en réalité le tissu
industriel du capitalisme dont je suis
un fervent défenseur
parfait
non
mais je je je pourrait m'expliquer de
ceux de ce choix étant le fils d'un
anarchiste catalan ça peut paraître un
peu un peu particulier et des faux
billets il
ne faisait pas des faux billets mais
s'il nous reste quelques secondes on
pourra parler de du seul moment dans
l'histoire humaine où l'anarchie a pu
devenir une réalité et c'était en 1935
36 dans le nord de l'espagne je ferme
cette parenthèse je suis un pro
capitalistes trop libérale je n'aime pas
le néo libéralisme anglo-saxon mais
si je reviens à l'adoption du
capitalisme son tissu industriel était
constituée d'hommes et de femmes qui
avait acquis une compétence et qui
créent leur entreprise
aujourd'hui cette notion de start up
elle est née dans une autre forme de
cette conceptualisations je pense que
c'est un mot qui va revenir souvent ce
soir je
j'ai l'habitude de dire et c'est très
très mal perçue dans ma communauté que
l'un des problèmes les plus les
plus problématiques
c'est que mes mes confrères parfois les
plus brillants ont
des raisonnements conceptuel
d'une rigueur absolue mais
qu'ils partent sur des fondements qui
sont faux et
dans la notion de start up il y à ce
principe de dire et
ça c'est très silicon valley très côte
ouest des états unis voilà on des grands
family office m'ont confié un milliard
de dollars eh bien je vais mettre des
tickets de 10 15 20 millions sur des
centaines d'entreprises il
y en a 80 % qui vont se casser la figure
il y en a 10 9% qui vont faire 0
bon et puis on a un pour cent ça sera à
microsoft ça sera pareil ça sera tesla
etc alors
ça fonctionne ça fonctionne par rapport
à une communauté qui
est très particulière je les ai
découvertes parce que j'ai fait la plus
grosse transaction de la vie qui a été
un placement de 700 millions d'euros a
été fait pour une société de la silicon
valley et
ce pour une raison simple c'est que
effectivement son président était un
européen européen et qu'il avait envie
d'avoir un je dirais une une touche
européenne dans le tour de table de ces
dossiers banquier conseil peu importe et
j'ai longuement décortiquée cet
entrepreneur sur le plan de ses
motivations alors je me suis aperçu que
nous voulons transposer
un business model en europe continentale
qui
n'existe que dans la région de san
francisco et de sa banlieue c'est un
autre choix très très particulier où
effectivement on
je
dirais l'argent est devenu quelque chose
d'assez abstrait d'ailleurs la preuve la
plus magnifique que nous avons en ce
moment c'était cela je veux dire si vous
me donnez des titres tesla en
rémunération d'une dette que vous auriez
à mon égard je la prendrai avec une
décote à l'est de 95 % d'accord
pourquoi parce que je pense que la
société tesla même si elle a perdu 15%
récemment elle vaut aller 5
6% de cette valeur déjà monté dans une
tesla je suis monté dans ce test là vous
êtes monté dans d'autres voitures
électriques je suis monté dans d'autres
voitures électriques absolument pas je
peux même vous dire une époque où j'ai
eu quelques relations avec le groupe
bolloré j'avais que j'avais conduit sur
l'anneau à quimper les toutes premières
voitures
équipées de de deux batteries de
batteries bolloré oui je je je vois bien
de quoi nous parlons pourquoi simplement
parce que vous plaît qu'on reste
quelques secondes sur ce sujet et ça va
éclairer justement la différence entre
mon économie réelle en avant que vous
vous continuez je préviens la communauté
on va parler de crise le coc vide et
surtout de dette de politique publique
de démocratie et et surtout ce qui nous
pour nous dit je vous laisse continuer
absolument et tout ça va être parsemé de
l'idée de l'optimisme et du déni mais
peuvent tout du déni oui mais aussi
d'une fosse de mon point de vue une
fausse idée que l'on se fait de
l'optimisme mais nous allons revenir là
dessus tesla c'est extrêmement simple
dans
mon univers c'est un univers où je
considère que je joue mes camarades nous
sommes malheureusement encore en tant
qu'être humain astreint à la loi de la
pesanteur c'est
assez assez con comme remarque c'est
quand on jette un bon kid afférents
l'air il retombe toujours bien alors
forman ya eu des sketches se répandent
laitages c'est ça il ya eu il ya eu des
sketches 8 après 2008 ouais après après
2008 il ya eu quelques sketches surtout
à la à la télévision anglaise mais qui
était extraordinaire et la 2 et 1 les
temps la question qui était fait comment
dirais-je à un humoriste qui était
supposé représenter un banquier de la
city donc avec son costume rayé et sa
grosse cravate à pois et qui lui dit
mais pourquoi pourquoi un banquier se
présentent-ils comme étant un être très
intelligent et et l'humoriste répond ait
dit oui à verts eelv est très bon et en
fait l'outil chaque soir de breuty jax
absolument est en fait qu est-ce qui
commet il démons se dit mais c'est très
facile
nous avons été capables nous les grands
banquiers nous avons s'est dit capable
de rendre
robles un sdf plutôt
noir plutôt borgne plutôt handicapés
riches pendant
un instant qui a duré un an ou deux ans
il ya quand même de l'intelligence et
cbc c'est d'un cynisme attendait c'est
d'un cynisme total or
mes clients ne peuvent pas être cynique
quand
on est quand on est à laval périgueux
tournée ou frosinone au sud de rome on
ne peut pas être cynique on est astreint
à des contraintes humaines familiale
juridique enfin on est astreint à des
contraintes on peut avoir le sens de
l'humour on peut prendre à la légèreté
certaines choses pour rendre la vie un
peu plus facile on peut pas être au site
or
le cynisme de tesla est très simple
étant astreint à la pesanteur vous
avez une entreprise technologique qui a
eu effectivement un vrai talent dans la
conception de ses batteries qui
a eu de l'avant ce qui aujourd'hui jo je
crois qu dernière valorisation c'était
650 milliards de dollars alors que ça
bouge tout le temps mais en gros
volkswagen mercedes et bmw doivent être
entre 30 et 50 ok on
ne dit que tesla mérite cette
valorisation alors qu'ils ne produisent
même pas 10% de ce que produisent les
autres parce que c'est une société
technologique mais on rêve les trois
entreprises allemandes dont je viens de
vous parler sont des entreprises qui
sont gavés
de technologie ils ont des mines et de
brevets sur l'hydrogène sur les
laiteries sur la voiture autonome et
c'est donc on survalorise
une société parce qu'elle devient
emblématique et
ça et ça c'est une idée c'est une des
duperies du système c'est qu'il faut
aller chercher des emblèmes et c'est
parce que la méthode de valorisation la
plus jeune dont le monde financier
anglo-saxon est une méthode par les
comparables donc à partir du moment où
tu es cela est qualifié de sociétés
technologiques on
la compare alors que c'est un carrossier
qui assemble des batteries des roues etc
on va là sans qu'on va la comparer en
termes du multiple à deux sociétés comme
amazon qui elle même est une société
hybride 1 dans la mesure où jusque avant
le pot vide elle ne gagnait pas d'argent
sur son activité coeur métier de de
e-commerce mais a eu ce talent bravo
monsieur berdos a eu ce talent de se
mettre dans les services est
essentiellement deux clubs dans le cloud
bon donc en fait on mélange les concepts
on mélange les concepts pour obtenir
pour obtenir un champion et ce qui me
renvoie à la start up nation qu'est ce
qu'on cherche on cherche à nous dire
mais
non mais non et non et yéyé confiance de
mon problème de l'optimisme ayez
confiance puisque
ceux qui vont être totalement maître et
possesseur de la technologie vont
presque mécaniquement faire fortune ah
non et là où j'ai un problème et c'est
là où le cynisme me fait mal c'est que
je veux témoigner devant devant vos
caméras du nombre de gens qui
aujourd'hui souffrent de leurs enfants
qui se sont lancés dans une aventure en
piquant le pe a le machin le livre est
une défiscalisation fin bref pour
amorcer et qui à la limite qu'ils
ruinent et on va ruiner kill kill the
kills est amputé l'epargne de leur
environnement tant pis pour eux mais
c'est pas ça mon problème c'est que ont
créé une génération de frustrés parce
que on leur a dit vous êtes dans la
nation dans la start up nation donc il
est légitime que qu'un post ado de 18 20
22 ans se disent donc
je donc je vais réussir dans mon garage
et quand ils se trouvent confrontés aux
lettres recommandées de l'urssaf qui lui
demande de payer il
est désespéré le gamin donc
sachant que nous n'avons pas de
statistiques
j'en ai piqué quelques-unes dans mes
recherches on oscille entre eux 92 95 98
% d'échec au terme de poids deux ans
trois ans cinq ans et encore on mélange
là dedans dans la start-up celui qui
crée une société de services dans la
plomberie à l'image et lui il à 95% de
chances de réussir d'accord d'abord
parce qu'il connaît le métier de
plombier et qu'il est capable d'être un
prestataire de services donc j'ai ouï
une vraie inquiétude sociétale
vous allez voir d'ailleurs que je vais
la développer plus largement parce que
on fait des fausses promesses alors
que pour des raisons électorales
monsieur macron que monsieur johnson que
monsieur peu importe je dirais tous les
tous les adeptes du néo libéralisme
anglo-saxon s'est choisie à dessein oui
pourquoi ça fait un peu secte mais c'est
parce que c'est une croyance c'est
une vraie croyance est là où je risque à
l'issue de notre rencontre d'être brûlé
j
en place de grève c'est que on n'a pas
le droit on n'a pas le droit de dire que
ce système n'est pas certain
de réussir je dis pas ça bien sûr qu'il
y aura des succès mais à partir du
moment où vous en faites un programme de
vie attention
à la déception humaine attention à la
création de frustration qui vont
d'ailleurs contribué à un autre aspect
que j'espère pouvoir développer ce soir
qui est ce phénomène totalement
incompréhensible de l'effondrement de la
productivité dans les pays occidentaux y
venir noé absolue je voudrais qu'on
vienne sur votre lecture on va dire
votre lecture de vieux boomer de la
banque sur la crise de 2008 sur qu'est
ce qui a généré cette crise et pourquoi
il y a que très peu de personnes en
prison
alors en
fait j'ai
commencé j'ai
commencé à être totalement
perplexe sur ce que je vivais il
y à 22 23 ans c'est à dire dans les
années qui ont précédé la bulle internet
parce
qu'en réalité pour répondre à la bulle
de 2007-2008 il faut comprendre celle
d'avant où
justement justement ayant
été un des petits mozart des
introductions en bourse de la place de
paris pas seulement paris de bruxelles
de milan lui se sent plus de 100
sociétés sur le marché entre 96 et 2001
vous avez pris combien votre poche ah
ben ça a été les anneaux et ça a été les
années fantastiques dans
ma poche dans le jeu je ne dirais pas
mais j'ai pris des centaines de milliers
d'euros ouais des centaines de milliers
de mai
mais j'ai fait gagner à tout
l'écosystème et à mes clients des
dizaines ou des centaines de millions
d'euros donc alors
je me déculpabilisant disant ça mais
mais voilà c'était un écosystème où de
new york à londres en passant par genève
par milan blessé par singapour par
shanghai je veux dire c'était
c'était la fête au village il y avait il
y avait abondamment les
mécanismes d effet de bulle on peut il
revenir trente secondes mais ils sont
connus mais ils sont connus maintenant
depuis je
dirais depuis la fin du moyen âge depuis
la foyer du moyen âge parce qu'ils sont
deux qui mentent et depuis la fin du
moyen-âge je suis presque convaincu que
les phéniciens qui jouait avec leurs
coquillages pour utiliser cet outil
monétaire il devait il veille avoir sur
des enfants l'huile d'olive ou ou sur ou
sur des marchands d'esclaves un
autre cynisme il devait y avoir des
phénomènes de bulles mais on sait depuis
surtout le xvème xvième siècle des
mécanismes de bulle en fait le principe
reste toujours le même c'est le principe
d'un
rendement économique naturel qui dépérit
et
que l'on va vouloir le on étend les
élites alors
les élites avec un z c'est c'est
toujours les mêmes ces démarches en cd
héritiers à l'époque des aristocrates
c'est des nouveaux riches c'est
d'accueillir un cellulaire leclerc a le
jus à
part d'en prendre oui leclerc aussonne
non non pas de du supermarché oui
[Rires]
oui oui oui il ya de ça il ya de ça mais
en fait le vrai point c'est
que ces élites elles attirent tout le
monde elle attire les artistes
elle attire la
mode les musiciens les savants
léonard de vinci était était dans
l'environnement je dirais des puissants
et des nantis parce que parce que c'est
cette relation où on a on a besoin
d'argent il faut de l'argent etc mais si
je mets de côté tous ceux qui sont les
les supports intellectuelle vous avez
ceux dont la préoccupation première
c'est d'accroître
la fortune leurs fantômes nasa richelieu
charles quint adoré le pognon je le dit
adorer surtout pouvoir oui parce que
parce que c'est un outil pouvoir est
donc un moment où les récoltes
dépérissent à un moment où les gars lion
d'or arrivants sombre
pas porte quelles que soient les raisons
il y à un mécanisme d'enrichissement
artificielle
qui
revêt des situations tout à fait
différente à chaque fois en termes de
d'origine
l'origine
est à chaque fois différent la pandémie
est différente de la crise et quand on
voit la bulle financière depuis le mois
d'avril la
pandémie n'a pas été le mouvement avec
le départ mais la crise de 2008 c'est
donc un clone de celle de 2001 2002
c'est un rebond dans la mesure où est
ce que vous imaginez que ddd
sachant ont publié dans le wall street
journal dans les années 2000 5 6 une
phrase en disant il faut que monsieur
greenspan qui était le patron de la
réserve fédérale américaine crée une
bulle ça a été écrit je le reprends dans
il
faut qu'il recrée une bulle
vraisemblablement immobilière pour
effacer
l'effondrement de la bulle des valeurs
internet enfin
je veux dire quand on dit ça je pense
que
l'essentiel de votre auditoire va dire
mais il est fou ce type c'est pas vrai
si c'est vrai c'est documenté taf taf
est avérée or que se passe-t-il il se
passe que effectivement les
effets euphorisants de
l'argent c'est en terminer avec
l'implosion de la bulle eh ben il
fallait en créer une autre il
s'est avéré que pour des raisons que
je ne connais pas l'ensemble
de ceux de ce phénomène c'est pas un
complot c'est un alignement d'intérêt
est allé vers l'immobilier bon il aurait
pu aller vers les matières premières il
aurait pu aller vers le marché de l'art
enfin quoiqu'il ait beaucoup plus
restreint mais c'est le marché de l'art
exploser les matières premières
explosent absolument absolument mais
pourquoi c'est parce que vous avez à la
proue de la bulle vous avez en 2000 en
dans les années antérieures il y avait
eu l'asie ensuite il ya eu les valeurs
internet et là il y avait l'immobilier
effectivement maintenant c'est quoi
c'est
le rêve que la digitalisation du monde
va recréer une nouvelle vague de
croissance le
le dogme il est là la numérisation le
big data l'intelligence artificielle
tout ça c'est le ce sont des synonymes
du même nom c'est con numérise vos
expériences et que en optimisant
l'exploitation de cette numérisation
on va créer un rebond de
croissance donc d'enrichissement réel et
donc d'enrichissement patrimonial alors
2000 ça joue la même poche de toujours
apporter mes besoins oui si ce n'est que
pour paraphraser le père d'un ami le
jour de l'élection de françois
mitterrand il s'agit dit non
non mes enfants ça va rien changer les
cigares vent changeait de bouche simic
mais dans les faits en dehors des jours
de show i d'un peuple de gauche qui
s'est dit voilà on va on va enfin avoir
quelqu'un aurait été c'est ce qui se
passe c'est ce qui s'est passé avec le
capitalisme c'est très bien portés avec
des nouveaux riches qui viennent
remplacer des anciens etc vous
m'avez posé une question donc la
mécanique elle est toujours la même
c'est le fait qu'il faut créer de la
valeur quand on ne crée plus de
richesses il faudra qu'on assiste là
dessus ce soir on crée du patrimoine
voilà on crée du patrimoine là où la
collectivité ne crée plus de richesses
qu'elles sont les richesses des biens et
des services qui
sont produits pour améliorer l'existence
des êtres humains quand
cette production des
choix alors on recrée des cdd et des
phénomènes de mieux pourquoi
il n'y a pas eu suffisamment de gens en
prison mais simplement parce que dans
l'immense majorité des cas ça a été fait
dans la légalité
pourquoi
parce que les lobbyings depuis
maintenant trente quarante cinquante ans
qui
était au début de ma vie professionnelle
des lobbyings des
entrepreneurs industriels est devenu le
lobbying des entrepreneurs financier est
principalement anglo-saxons donc ils
sont que ce soit à côté démocrate ou
travaillistes en angleterre ou des who
ou du côté conservateur aux républicains
c'est du kif c'est pourquoi ces 2 10
messieurs les politiques moi j'ai
souvenez vous ayem veut y crève le même
je suis tellement intelligent que je
vais créer
de la valeur et que cette valeur va
entraîner l'ensemble de la population
qui va voter pour vous qui va être
heureuse etc
donc faites nous passer la loi nous
permettant 2 et comme en plus on était
dans un processus de déréglementation
depuis
les
années 90 depuis le l'aveu même avant
même même avant en fait satcher est
arrivé me soit + 87 et
non même le néolibéralisme est arrivé
avant mais n'oublions pas que le
néolibéralisme par rapport au
libéralisme je suis pro capital et pro
libéral c'est que le libéral que je suis
il aime la réglementation il veut que le
marché soit réglementée parce que si on
pense que le marché va selick
s'équilibrer de façon autonome sans
qu'il y ait des garde-fous stade c'est
une utopie donc il faut de la
réglementation donc quand on passe du
libéralisme au néolibéralisme et bien en
fait c'est pour les mêmes raisons c'est
qu'étant donné qu'il y avait une baisse
de la performance économique
richelle sa biens et services du
profits dégagés par la production de ce
bien et de services de ses biens et de
ses services ont des réglemente ont fait
passer des lois qui autorise les gens à
spéculer plus librement à s'endetter
plus librement etc et ont créé les
conditions légales pour qu'il y ait un
phénomène de bulle quand il ya par
exemple gamestop vous avez suivi un peu
non ils sont tous tous venus chouiner
pour avoir de la réglementation derrière
ça pleurait beaucoup quand ils se sont
fait déculottée par le petit
investisseur qui avait décidé de si vous
me permettez d'être vulgaire de le
remettre bien bon ils
sont venus pleurer ouais donc c'est à
dire que ils n'ont pas besoin de
régulation quand il tout va bien pour
eux mais quand ça va mal pour eux
ils veulent de la régulation c'est ça
c'est
une des ambiguïtés de notre siècle du
21e siècle c'est que en fait on prône la
liberté individuelle mais
dès que ça va mal on veut que l'état
intervienne et
on le voit avec le que vite je
veux prendre mon verre de bière place
de la république quand je jouais avec
mes copains et sans masque sait comment
il ya un problème alors il faut que
l'état intervienne et
ça c'est pas c'est pas place de la
république à ses seins piccadilly circus
et cc c'est un phénomène je dirais qu'il
a même dépassé l'occident c'est à dire
l'europe et l'amérique du nord je pense
qu'il est mondiale mais je reviens je
reviens à votre problème en fait on me
posant la question de 2002 la crise de
2007 je vous ai dit je vous ai donné mon
sentiment sur l'origine fondamental de
tout de tout bull mais il faut que je
rentre un petit peu dans le détail le
détail c'est que depuis
les années 30 g pas retrouvé de traces
formelle
sur le jour où le mot de croissance a
été senti
fier sacralisé
mais
ces nez avec les comptabilités publiques
donc je je je soupçonne que c'est à peu
près dans les années 30 que le mot de
croissance et arrive donc il ya 90 ans
depuis
50 ans le
socle de nos existences de
vos auditeurs de de nous tous de nos
familles c'est la croissance il ya cette
boussole ou alors
c'est la religion pas absolument c'est
la religion dans le fait que cette
croissance comme le progrès sera
perpétuelle
votre progrès pour un vieux boomer alors
pour moi le progrès nono
nos
grands parents je dirai tout ce qu'ils
ont vécu après victor hugo qui a été un
des grands progressiste humaniste
que que j'aime c'est donnons aux êtres
humains les
moyens de l'amélioration de leur
existence est
temps qu'ils ont eues ces moyens c'était
quoi c'était une cité du transport
c'était de l'éducation c'était de la
santé publique c'était de l'énergie
c'était de l'eau courante c'était des
aliments qu'ils pouvaient être conservés
enfin bref dès qu'on a on est passé de
ce stade où les paysans vivaient
dans
des maisons où c'étaient des sols en
terre battue donc dès qu'il pleuvait
c'était c'était la gadoue chez eux enfin
je veux dire les conditions de vie
devait
être changé et on a entre le milieu du
xviiie siècle et le milieu du 19e siècle
on a un ponte stablement en europe
permis que l'essentiel de ces
populations et obtenu des éléments de
progrès c'est quoi grâce à plusieurs
choses au charbon alors
grâce à
des matières premières grâce à le début
d'un surplus agricoles qui fait qu'il a
créé un petit capital qui a permis de
financer d'autres activités marchandes
ou industrielle s'avère donc il ya
toujours un moment la notion surplus
entre guillemets c'est pour ça que je
suis pro capitale c'est qu' il
n'y a pas d'activités humaines stable
s'il n'ya pas surplus au profit je ferme
septembre
il y a eu surtout le progrès technique
et
ce progrès techniques dans les années
à 1950
se prend la croissance de cette
productivité a été constante
donc il nous a donné ce sentiment
délicieux extraordinaire on
on devient des dieux vivants puisque
notre
progrès et éternelle or
depuis 1950
60 selon les pays la
croissance de la productivité s'est
effondré ça on sait que c'est votre
marotte et on va y revenir d'accord pour
des attardés et donc baisse de la
productivité baisse du profit des
activités industrielles et
n'ayant plus ni vraie croissance
autonome ni croissance des profits ou
maintien des niveaux de profits qu'est
ce qu'on fait on recrée des moyens
artificiels de créer du patrimoine va
revenir à la dette on va revenir à
toutes les questions je suis en train de
lire les questions qu avec l'oeil droit
sur le hft tout ça on va évidemment et
revenons aux crises est-ce que vous
pensez que les gouvernements occidentaux
ou pris l'ampleur des répercussions
d'une crise financière sur la société
réelle où ils se sont tous tentés à
d'imprimer de la dette d'imprimer des
billets pour artificiellement créé
une croissance
l'illusion
de croissance est ce que est ce que vous
prenez 1960 la baisse de la productivité
mots gelés je prends plus 1972 oui
j'attends d'eux premier choc pétrolier
absolument mais premier choc pétrolier
on nous la france on n'a pas de pétrole
mais on a des idées là on a commencé
industries de service et je vous en
passe et des meilleures donc est ce que
vous voyez une connexion entre la
raréfaction d'une énergie pas cher avec
des banquiers qui ou des banquiers et
des gouvernements qui ont été habitués
dorloter être
dépressif prestidigitateur de croissance
et est ce que vous voyez une corrélation
entre énergie baisse de productivité et
agitation nos gouvernants et nos
banquiers oui oui je
suis fier du métier que je fais parce
que je considère que
modestement
parce que ce sont ce sont mes clients
qui font le job mais on vient leur
apporter des
idées ou des moyens est
d'ailleurs fondamentalement il nous
rémunère pour ça des idées des moyens
qui vont les
aider à réaliser leurs rêves qui eux est
de créer de la richesse pas du
patrimoine maintenant il ya confusion et
en heure on y reviendra mais de créer de
la richesse pour
moi il est absolument certain que parce
que choc pétrolier parce que l'énergie
est devenu plus cher donc impact
sur la croissance et
bah il fallait il fallait donner des
substitutions il fallait compenser ou la
tête est une promesse de travail futures
ou d'énergie future alors justement le
problème c'est que quand
aujourd'hui je constate dans la presse
depuis des années
il ya un mot qui est admis par par tout
le monde sait nous sommes dans une phase
de croissance à crédit ça ne fait plus
peur enfin je veux dire qu'on soit
d'extrême gauche d'extrême droite tout
le monde se satisfait de ce constat bon
d'accord on vit dans une croissance à
crédit et alors et alors
quand
je prends parce
que ça a été ça mon point de départ donc
je rappelle je vis internet je commence
à me dire mais qu'est ce qui se passe je
me pose des questions et en 2012 je
tombe sur un article de la banque
fédérale qui éveille qui éveille la
curiosité et quand je veux satisfaire ma
curiosité qu'est ce que je découvre je
découvre que et je veux prendre l'année
2018 en
2018 aux états unis pour obtenir une
croissance affichée de 3% le déficit du
budget américain a été de 6% donc dix
ans après le krach de ce prime pourquoi
dans un pays qui est gavé technologie
qui commence à avoir du pétrole un bon
avec des effets de pollution dont on
parlera peut-être mais qui commence à
avoir du pétrole qui peuvent exploiter
parce que le pétrole étant cher on peut
on peut exploiter le les schistes
bitumineux comment
pour quelle raison ont-ils l'obligation
de 200 dt 2 6% du pib de plus pour ne
générer que trois réponse
politiquement correct wiba la croissance
et 1 est à crédit et à ce moment là j'ai
fait le l'abominable binger
soustrait pourquoi
parce que j'ai des amis qui ont des
cursus dans la comptabilité stupéfiants
en france et en europe
et qui m'ont rappelé quand je leur ai
dit mais ce que j'ai le droit de faire
la soustraction et quand il écoute il ya
un principe de sincérité comptable c'est
qu'il faut déduire de tout agrégats
économiques
les éléments négatifs qui lui contribuer
bout qui lui correspondent donc j'ai le
droit de déduire du déficit le
montant enfin de la croissance le
montant du déficit et qu'est ce que je
vois je vois que les etats-unis sont à
-3% en 2018 - 3 % sur une année ça veut
dire que les états unis sont en
récession ah non non non non ça c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible de dire
ça et à ce moment là je poursuis mon mon
ma réflexion et mon enquête
et qu'est ce que je découvre c'est que
depuis mes 50 ans donc depuis 1970 80 %
du temps les etats unis du fait de ce
mécanisme sont en récession non mais
est-ce que c'est audible ça n'est pas
audible
ces sites c'est une folie c'est une
démence on peut on peut pas envisager ça
je le fais sur l'angleterre c'est la
même chose je le fais sur la france et
la même chose dans des proportions
toutes différentes mais le constat est
le même et c'est là où j'arrive
mois avec une
rupture puisqu'on parle de disruptif je
pense que là je suis vraiment disruptif
en disant mais regardons regardons la
réalité l'économie
occidentale si elle n'était pas
biberonné c'est aussi un mot qu'on
entend à la dette publique serait tu en
récession touche sexy comme un shooter
avec le public mais c'est la même chose
mais c'est la même chose par contre là
où je voudrais qu'on passe le plus de
temps possible
c'est qu'une fois qu'on aura bien
compris les mécanismes en amont nous
sommes dans une absurdité dont
la toxicité n'a pas encore été révélée
publiquement c'est
que pour générer 3
% de croissance affichés il faut non
seulement 6 % de dette publique mais il
faut que la dette privée qui
représente toujours on en as deux fois
plus que la dette publique soit dans la
même proportion c'est à dire on est
rentrés depuis 30 ans et le processus
s'accélère c'est à dire qu'il faut
recourir à de plus en plus de dettes
pour de moins en moins de croissance
alors
justement balle ça mène déjà un premier
constat et quand je dis ça je me fais
traiter de chou mais je ne suis pas la
différence entre avoué un fou et moi non
je ne la connais pas c'est que fout moi
je moi je sais que je ne suis pas fou
mais c'est passé de blague là je vous
laisse continuer bas mais j'attends la
réponse c'est
que nous avons nous sommes dans une
situation extrêmement
étrange où nous ne pouvons ni annuler ni
rembourser
notre dette j'ai à peine caricatural ça
veut dire que là il faut réellement
faire preuve d'imagination et de courage
et d'optimisme parce
que ce ne sont pas les 26 experts qui
ont été désignés par notre président de
la république qui vont sortir du câble
je rebondis à ce que vous me disiez tout
à l'heure non il n'y a pas de complot
parler
de complot non mais il
n'y a pas de complot il ya un alignement
d'intérêt on appelle ça la théorie du
plancton c'est sont tellement coup ils
avancent tous en nuage oui mais il ya
une merveilleuse légende du allemande du
moyen-âge du joueur de flûte vous
les petits rats derrière lui oui mais
vous la résume en 10 secondes un village
est infesté de rats il ya un joueur de
flûte qui arrive le maire du village dit
vous avez un moyen d'enlever les rails
le joueur de flûte dit oui je pense que
j'en ai un écoute si tu nous débarrasse
de nora on te donne mille écus fortune
pour l'époque donc le joueur de flûte
emmène les les rats dans la rivière va
chercher sa paye qui lui est refusé et à
ce moment là pour se venger il
recommence à jouer de nuit nuitamment
lire commence à jouer de la flûte pour
emmener tous les enfants de la ville
dans un lieu qui n'a jamais été révélé
mais on est aujourd'hui en train de joux
de suivre des flûtistes le seul problème
mais
on mais on est dans cette situation le
seul problème c'est que un moment où
grâce à internet grâce je veux dire à un
échange d'informations permanents
comment se fait-il que l'on en soit à ce
point de de jeu dur et de stupidité on
n'est pas stupides c'est qu'étant donné
que nous n'avons pas les réponses
faciles
électorale
électoralement plaisante pour
adresser le problème devant lequel nous
sommes on
poursuit jeu
je lis une question internet de truffes
d'ailleurs pourquoi changer parce que
tout va bien alors il va bien pour
l'instant ouais mais vous connaissez
l'histoire de celui qui descend de la
tour et à chaque étage il dit sofa
secondes jusque jusqu'à maintenant tout
se passe bien non
c'est pas la chute alors
c'est pour terry sage oui c'est
l'atterrissage c'est ça alors pourquoi
et j'espère que ça ne sera pas la
mémoire que que vos auditeurs vont
garder de moi parce que je suis un
optimiste farouche pas incrédule mais un
optimiste farouche pourquoi
je peux dresser un tableau apocalyptique
c'est
parce que et je pense que nous avons à
l'est entre 3 et 5 ans pour réagir on
n'a pas plus pour
réagir pour définir les 25 ans qui vont
suivre parce que pour changer le
paradigme il faut une génération même
il faut une génération par contre le top
départ du changement pour le préparer il
faut qu'il y ait un top départ de
l'acceptation de la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes faire l'avocat du
diable vrai alors je vous laisse
continuer mais je préfère je me mets en
mode avocat du diable seul ça risque de
piquer un peu continuer bon alors vision
apocalyptique
j'ai
fait plusieurs transactions dans
mon jargon on appelle ça débile dans le
le génie civil l'intelligence
des ingénieurs du sol et de la
construction il ya un truc qui terrorise
les plus anciens c'est
la liquéfaction des sols la
liquéfaction des sols c'est que ici cet
immeuble qui a été construit sous os man
peut-être
qu'il est sur une zone que l'on
considère comme étant géologie
géologiquement stable et qui en fait
boum s'effondre
c'est la liquéfaction des sols ma
crainte c'est la leaf et la liquéfaction
de denon simple c'est à dire de nos
sociétés de la deux de nos vies de
citoyens dans
un pays riche et encore démocratique qui
investissent dans les baskets c'est
pourquoi non parce que la fourche ça
pique alors
oui mais cette
blague et en être mise de côté pour pour
le moment le falloir
très vite alors le seul problème c'est
que quand je dis ça je pense que je dois
séduire ceux
qui ont une vision catastrophique
du monde mais
j'ai pas envie de ça j'ai vraiment pas
envie de ça et même si l'amour de ma vie
et moi nous n'avons pas trouvé comment
on fait des bébés nous avons eu toujours
dans chez nous des enfants qui
sont qui ont aujourd'hui entre 20 et 35
ans ont les âmes c'est qu'on les aime
ces gosses et je n'ai pas envie compte
tenu de la niaque qui me reste encore
pendant quelques années j'ai pas envie
de leur laisser une situation dans
laquelle il n'est pas une bouée de
sauvetage qu'est
ce que c'est que ces tickets faction
c'est que si effectivement monsieur
truffe dit qu'on peut continuer il a
raison les raisons aujourd'hui on peut
continuer pourquoi
pourquoi ça peut pas marcher ça peut pas
marcher parce qu'il ya ce que j'ai dit
il ya 10 minutes c'est ce phénomène
d'accélération de la dette globale
publics et privés pour un résultat des
croissants
quand je faisais mes études
il ya donc une cinquantaine d'années il
y avait un homme qui était considéré
comme vraiment c'était fini s'était
terminée on n'allait plus jamais en
parler c'était malthus les
rendements décroissants de la terre à
gré ah ben non grâce au projet technique
c'est fini c'est terminé
il n'y aura plus jamais de rendement
décroissant sur terre même s'il y en a
un sur la dette la
dette est rentré dans un processus où si
je voulais un il fallait mettre 2 enfin
il fallait mettre un d'abord il a fallu
mettre 0,50 donc là c'était bénéfique
total ensuite il a fallu y mettre un
impôt rhin et d'après makine z après
alors là c'est très difficile pour
trouver de l'info là dessus sur tout le
reste de ce que je vais vous dire on
trouve beaucoup d'informations quand on
cherche mais sur ce rendement
décroissant de la dette il faut il faut
aller il faut aller la chercher la
formation alors
j'en ai trouvé un peu dans il ya une
base de données époustouflante quand on
sait l'utiliser c'est la base de la
réserve fédérale de saint louis qui
a le nom m'échappe fred fred il ya une
base de données qui s'appelle fred comme
et il y a beaucoup beaucoup de choses
quand on cherche et quand on s'est
cherché dans cette dans cette base de
données mais le journal forbes a publié
sur
cet effondrement de l'efficacité de la
dette chinoise en ce moment il ya saxo
bank qui a fait un article donc vous
avez des par petites touches on arrive à
trouver mais moi je le vois dans la
mesure où pour augmenter la performance
capitalistique du monde aujourd'hui on
augmente l'endettement global
or ça veut dire quoi eh ben ça veut dire
que la dette qui est de 2500 milliards
donc ça veut dire qu'elle est de
aujourd'hui on est à une dette
collective publique et privée qui est de
300 % du pib' c'est les ordres de
grandeur avant que vides avant que vides
bon alors on peut passer à 400 on peut
passer à 500 etc qu'est-ce qui se passe
il
ya un homme que je lis beaucoup qui est
considéré comme étant un peu négatif
cc monsieur artus et
qui dit le problème n'est pas la dette
le problème c'est les liquidités
j'ai sur moi parce que je les depuis que
je suis enseignant 1 j'ai été enseignant
un billet de cinq dollars pourquoi
j'ai ce billet parce que dans la monnaie
américaine
il ya une phrase non
c'est pas celle là c'est
que cette ce ce billet si vous permettez
de sortir pour le pour le lit non ok
absolument
le micro c'est la
traduction c'est que ce is not ce billet
et le cours légal pour toutes dettes
publiques ou privées toutes
dettes publiques ou privées cela
veut dire que un organisme qui s'appelle
réserve fédérale un prime de la dette
pour la partie billet on sait que ce
n'est que quelques quelques fractions de
la dette totale parce
que c'est la reconnaissance d'une dette
que
comptablement on
fasse une fausse promesse que
cette dette pourrait être au niveau
européen annulé je voudrais revenir là
dessus après c'est une fausse promesse
ça n'arrivera jamais la constitution
américaine j'ai pas lu la constitution
américaine mais elle peut répudier sa
date et voilà elle peut répudier
s'attaque mais en réalité pourquoi deux
tiers encore aujourd'hui deux tiers des
échanges se font encore de l'art c'est
que c'est non pas in god we trust c'est
le green paper c'est la force qui vient
non pas de la faiblesse économique des
états unis mais qui vient de sa
domination dans tous les autres domaines
culturels scientifiques militaires
etc
donc c'est ont fait confiance dans cette
nation parce qu'effectivement elle
incarne la
puissance perpétuelle appelle la
puissance éternelle la liberté la
défense de l'opprimé ou des choses comme
ça exactement oui
je dirais sept fons de loups tribunal
c'est plutôt la défense j'ai créé deux
sociétés aux états unis dans les années
85 c'est vrai que ça ça a été fait chez
un avocat en échange d'un centime et en
20 minutes une
une au texas et une dans le delaware et
j'avais et j'avais de lower alors le de
la récession fiscale bien sûr mais c'est
simplement parce que les actionnaires
que j'avais et notamment la banque
royale du canada qui avait investi un
petit peu de sous dans mon aventure ma
vie et je vois pas pourquoi je vais
payer des impôts aux états unis alors qu
étant au-delà world je peux le rapatrier
au canada en franchise d'impôts plutôt
fallu dire le l'optimisation fiscale ne
doit pas être associé à de la fraude
fiscale optimisation fiscale c'est pas
de la fraude fiscale c'est quoi ces du
window dressing c'est quoi
l'optimisation
fiscale n'est en général dans l'excès de
taxation excès de taxation ou une
taxation qui est mal employé ou d'une
taxation qui est mal employé oui je peux
le faire ça je veux dire on dit toujours
la suite je peux vous assurer que la
suisse pour les résidents suisses n'est
pas du tout un paradis fiscal pas du
tout les suisses payent des impôts
sauf à zoug voilà je un petit village
sont
en conversion à 13% en ou alors ils sont
ils sont au dessus en impôts sur le
revenu et on appose sur les sociétés ils
doivent être à 10 ou 15% absolument à
vérifier puis jusqu'à 100 millions 0 je
peux pas vous dire je vois cent mille je
n'ai pas cette information enfin je n'ai
plus cette information en tout cas j'ai
vu des amis suisses et qui me disait tu
sais vous
sur certains aspects en france vous êtes
presque un paradis fiscal si on est
résident effectivement fiscale c'est
vrai qu'à partir d'un certain niveau ça
commence ça commence à taper mais il ya
eu aux états unis des impôts à plus de
70 ou 80% je n'ai fait que baisser pour
les plus riches et ça ne fait que
baisser pour les flics je
perds le fil parce que je voudrais
rester sur la notion de l'investissement
de dette de l'investissement et de
taxation d'euros où est le problème le
problème c'est que si on continue image
image parfaitement explicite pour le
public d'imprimer des billets c'est à
dire de créer de la dette en
fait en fait c'est pas la date elle même
qui pose le problème c'est la liquidité
qui restent pourquoi
parce que si j'ai face la dette comme
certaines des des comme certaines des
personnes qui sont venues sur ce plateau
le souhaitez moi
je parle de de monsieur giraud qui est
un honnête homme évident mais je pense
qu'il est enfin
joli joli gaël giraud depuis depuis des
années il est il est honnête il est
simple il est sincère mais il faut pas
qu'ils disent que l'on puisse annuler
cette dette l'allemagne ne le ne
l'acceptera jamais jamais alors la bce
c'est l'allemagne c'est pas parce que
l'état francfort
pas le dire mais il faut pas lire
pourquoi pourquoi
est ce que en 2021
on n'a pas enfin le droit de dire à des
dizaines ou des centaines de milliers de
personnes voilà ce qui va arriver
l'allemagne a mis sous tutelle la france
et l'europe c'est pas c'est pas une mise
sous tutelle c'est que nous bénéficions
de leur rigueur pour pouvoir emprunter
aux taux nous empruntons le
l'angleterre
pouvait sortir parce qu'elle n'était pas
elle n'était pas dans la zone euro elle
avait protégé alors ça c'était sa
croisade depuis le départ depuis le
départ d'accord mais nous nous celle de
trois langues le t1 alors
c'est la preuve que c'est possible et
c'est pour ça que mes camarades parce
que ce sont mes camarades de jeu néo
libéraux progressistes anglo saxon je
dirais d'obédience anglo
saxon ils
tireront à boulet rouge sur le principe
car il faut absolument que le break si
tu échoues il faut que ce soit une
catastrophe parce que sinon je dirais le
prochain sur la liste est un peu
l'italie qui peut à un moment ou un
autre se dire vous savez qu'il ya
certains de régions de l'italie où il
recrée leurs propres petites monnaies
locales donc je
n'en sais rien ça c'est de la politique
fiction jeu ça c'est un an j'en sais
rien ce que je sais c'est que
aujourd'hui sans
le support de l'allemagne la bce d'une
est
une organisation
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie banque
centrale
qui a la capacité de se financer sur les
marchés parce que elle est adossée à
l'allemagne et
que l'on sait que l'allemagne ne joue
pas avec la création monétaire pour une
simple raison ça leur a coûté 30 ans
d'ignominies 20 millions de morts
et vingt ans pour se reconstruire alors
ils vont pas ils vont pas accepter que
que ce soit arnaud
montebourg est
un camarade un jeu parce
que arnault est un type formidable enfin
je veux dire dans le bourg ben parce que
lui aussi voudrait voudraient annuler il
faudrait une fois que le cantonnement
est fait au niveau de la bce que la bce
par un jeu d'écritures qui est possible
qui est parfaitement possible mais un
jeudi que l'allemagne ne l'acceptera
jamais donc pourquoi faire une promesse
quand on sait qu'il y aura un veto de si
jamais ce qui à mon avis n'arrivera pas
c'était fait ça veut dire que toute la
construction qui était de dire l'euro
est un vrai concurrent de dollars est un
vrai concurrent du dollar parce que
c'est une monnaie forte eh ben elle est
émise par une par une banque qui doit
faire un ride of et peu fifo expie tu as
pardon qu'elle qu'elle doit provisionner
et donc constater une perte dans son
bilan et une perte qui fait qu'elle n'a
plus de fonds propres parce que comme le
disait il ya un giro il a raison les
fonds propres de la banque centrale
européenne sont très faibles et puis
troisièmement c'est mon point de ce soir
c'est que pour continuer d'avoir une
croissance apparente il faut continuer
de s'endetter il
est là le piège c'est que comment voulez
vous qu'on puisse arrêter la machine
puisqu'il
puisqu'elle est vitale et
mon point mon point il est clair c'est
que pour se désaccoutumer de ce
mécanisme je dit il faudra à peu près 25
ans pourquoi
25 ans parce que c'est une génération
pourquoi 25 ans parce que porte on
regarde entre la période de l'écu et la
période préparatoire de l'es2
de l'euro ça a été une vingtaine nouveau
25 ans voilà en gros en bout mais avant
de donner le top départ du ddea du jour
du jour du débarquement c'est à dire
allez maintenant on commence moi je
considère qu'il faut trois quatre ans de
de mise au point wen a vraiment
optimiste vous êtes vraiment y aller je
suis l timide alors je vais me faire un
peu la moue qui diable alors j'ai fait
une blague et que les banquiers qui
investissent dans les baskets pour
courir est ce que est ce que dans votre
milieu ça discute dans les couloirs
comme quoi les gens commencent à
s'énerver les gens commencent à
comprendre qu'on les a bercé pendant des
années avec de la croissance
artificielle basée sur de la dette
perpétuelle les
gens vont vouloir peut-être expliquer qu
ils sont pas contents et dans les cibles
potentielles des politiques et les
bandits les journalistes il ya tout ça
est ce que ça discute est ce qu'il ya un
petit sentiment d - qui frissonnent mot
près de la moelle épinière comme quoi ça
devient risqué je
suis désolé il va falloir qu'il fasse
une digression pour répondre à cette
question mais je vais je vais répondre
le
boomer que je suis et j'ai vraiment
bourlingué j'ai vraiment bourlingué
bourlingué
au sens que j'ai accompagné des gens de
toutes natures de tout âge dans des
métiers qui vont des nanotechnologies ou
textile en bref avant je suis fier et
content d'avoir d'avoir d'avoir fait ça
et parce que j'ai bourlingué je
suis je suis à même de dire ce soir que
quand on regarde avec un certain recul
comment tout ça fonctionne
comment tout ça fonctionne ça fonctionne
en fait sur un moteur à trois cylindres
le
premier cylindre c'est l'homme par
dont l'être humain l'être
humain dans dans
toute son acceptation ses peurs ses
croyances ses états d'âme son climat ses
lois ses coutumes etc tout ce qui touche
à l'homme le
deuxième si l'inde c'est l'économique et
j'en fais un cylindre séparé parce que
dans l'humain il y a beaucoup de
subjectivité et
que on trouve on trouvait à priori plus
de mécanismes plus
de wii 2 2 de mécanique dans la sphère
économique production
consommation investissement et
le troisième si l'inde c'est celui de la
finance qui
est il
ya la subjectivité la rationalité et la
finance je dirais c'est à la fois le
l'utilité et la magie l'utilité
c'est que sans finance les deux premiers
ne marche pas
la grippe ça bloque mais
la finance est un univers aussi
vaste que l'économique et l'humain c'est
à dire que qu'elle
est qu'elle l'est la comparaison entre
un associé
de goldman sachs à new york et
l'adorable
personnes qui s'occupent de la poste de
la banque postale à guéret enfin je veux
dire oui
c'est de kruger et c'est la creuse c'est
la ville de naissance de ma mère qui il
ya un très joli et roux domérat adacore
donc
très
très très fier d'avoir 50 % de non sens
qui vient de ceux de ce département
pathé pommes de terre exactement et
et le gâteau le gall le le
creusois absolument pas c'est
un peu une touche chrétien mais ça avec
les chrétiens mais il n'ya pas que les
4,1 ces trois cylindres de
mon point de vue pendant 200 ans on
était cinq rôles c'est
à dire que la vitesse de fonctionnement
des êtres humains dans le premier
cylindre et est synchrone de celle de
l'économie qui était synchrone de celle
de la finance aux
variations près de révolte de révolution
de deux guerres civiles de guerre civile
et de guerre mais sur la tendance sur la
tendance si on comment dirais-je on
soustrait ces épisodes très nombreux
très nombreux il y avait une certaine
synchronicité entre les trois quand
j'ai commencé à travailler
j'ai
eu la chance d'avoir deux dîners qui ont
marqué ce
jeune âge
chez quelqu'un qui certainement mort
depuis qui parce qu'il avait été dans le
club des compagnons de la libération
avait
un pouvoir politique tel qu'il avait
dans son immense appartement une
ou deux fois par an des dîners de patron
et
il y avait l'establishment et comme
j'étais copain du fils j'ai eu à deux
reprises la possibilité de participer à
ces à ces dîners quelle
était la fierté de ses patrons quand il
parlait c'était
le nombre d'employés ah
oui mon cher ami oui comment vous avez
déjà quinze mille vers ça mais c'est une
plantation de coton non oui mais
justement c'est pas comme d'alain
plantations de coton c'était parce que
le tissu humain
de ces entreprises wen ont été
déterminants et est absolument
déterminant cinquante
ans plus tard ce n'est même plus le
chiffre d'affaires qui est le le critère
de la performance c'est la valeur ou
boursières ou qui a été celle du dernier
tour de financement de la société donc
on est passé du cylindre c'est les
hommes qui sont à l'origine de tous au
cylindre c'est
le sait la fortune monétaire c'est la
fortune exclusivement capitalistique qui
représente la valeur de cet entrepreneur
est
pourquoi je dis ça avant de répondre à
votre réponse c'est parce que et
c'est pour ça que je n'aime pas le
néolibéralisme
c'est que parce que le fonctionnement
des deux premiers si l'inde s'est
trouvée infléchi c'est tout à
partir de soixante dix je suis d'accord
avec vous qu'il a fallu le compenser par
cette financiarisation du monde mais
elle est artificielle cette
financiarisation donc à partir du moment
où elle est artificielle
c'est là où je crains qu'elle ne
collaborent pas ce que et j'ai commencé
ma démonstration en disant que nous
sommes astreints à la pesanteur
comment voulez-vous que quelque chose
qui est en état d'apesanteur puisse
durer éternellement je dirais c'est
toujours monsieur truc qui posait la
question c'est ça je dirais ou madame je
dirais si
mais ma valeur de tesla ce que je
considère qu'elle est totalement
artificielle et
ben ça veut dire qu'à ce moment là la
valeur de bmw ou de volkswagen doit être
la même et
qu'on utilise les mêmes les mêmes
arguments dompter
cela vaut 800 milliards ben alors à ce
moment là volkswagen vos 1200 1500 1600
milliards ça veut dire quoi ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'hyper inflation
monétaire et
l'hyper inflation monétaire la
grand-mère de l'amour de ma vie était en
sarre dans les années 20 et elle m'avait
donné malheureusement je l' ai perdu un
millier un autre pas celui de 50 mille
milliards de marks qui était le prix
d'une boîte d'allumettes cinquante mille
milliards de marks s'en prenant à peu
près le pib de l'allemagne d'aujourd'hui
si on convertit en marque et
on sait et on sait le résultat et on
sait le résultat donc ah bah oui on peut
continuer mais alors là je le dis en
continuant cette logique absurde
perverse et toxiques alors est-ce que
c'est dans trois ans dans cinq ans je
pense par un médoc
et j'en reviens à mon univers comment
voulez vous dans mon univers qu'il soit
à genève à londres à paris dans le
triangle d'or c'est là où sont mes
bureaux etc comment voulez vous qu'on se
préoccupe de ça
et c'est là où je suis un banquier autre
échelle c'est que moi j'adore prendre
mon train mon tgv pour l'ouest de la
france à 6h15 et à regarder les les
cadres les mamies et ses acquis by où
on sent et j'aime bien aller voir alors
moi je peux vous dire que ce que vous
évoquez n'est pas dans la sphère mais
elle est au niveau des étages inférieurs
bien sûr dans
votre sphère est ce que ça discute du
fait que la colère gronde est ce qu'il
ya eu des sales et entendu à gauche ou à
droite des banquiers qui disait ben là
je me suis expatrié les campagnes j'ai
fait une panique rouge et un plan b j'ai
une société de sécurité qui peut arriver
en cinq minutes il peut m'expliquer très
ou des choses comme ça est-ce que les
super riches commencent
à sentir l'odeur de la peur
non parce que je pense que pour être
dans cette catégorie de personnes c'est
une blague que j'avais que j'avais
utilisé ou ali sud à l'issue de la bulle
internet où j'ai réellement permis un
certain nombre d'entrepreneurs de
faire fortune on peut lire une
avocate
m'avait demandé mais en quoi ce en quoi
ce caractéristiques cette personne il se
caractérise généralement il ya des
exceptions en
en
une personne qui depuis tout petit il
veut être le premier il veut être
excellents et ils considèrent que la
preuve d'être premier excellent c'est sa
richesse
et que si par malheur à l'issue d'une
nuit d'amour il ouvre un matin les
gelées et se dire que la vie est belle
le font pourquoi tout ça il ne sera
jamais arrive il
ne il ne doit jamais riche ultra riches
donc étant donné que j'avais quoi penser
à autre chose qu'à sa richesse
donc comment voulez vous qu'ils se
soucient des insectes utiles que nous
sommes n'ont
alors qu'il y en ait parce qu'ils ont un
certain âge il est absolument
incontestable que si je fais c'est
caricatural mais ça valide et si je fais
si je regarde tous les jeunes qui ont
autour
de 20 ans il ya une inquiétude et
un climat d'incertitude si
je regarde à l'opposé ceux qui ont 70
plus un vrai sentiment d'inquiétude et
qu'ils soient riches ou pauvres qu'il a
70 et
ne le répétez pas mais
moi j'ai une âme qui s'est arrêté à 40
ans je veux dire je suis le vide et
cheveux annonçant heureusement c'est
parti à 22 ans donc problème leurs
propres problèmes réglés etc non j'ai
une niaque d'enfer et je considère que
parmi mes associés je suis l'aîné je
suis le plus jeune parce
que moi je me soucie des 40 50 ou je ne
serai plus là mais j'ai vraiment mais
vraiment envie de consacrer les
dernières années de gnac que j'ai pour
effectivement amélioré les choses donc
grande inquiétude aux deux extrémités de
la pyramide des âges au milieu
il y avait une inquiétude mais c'est une
inquiétude liée au travail c'est une
inquiétude liée voilà le problème de la
dette et c'est l'inquiétude dont vous
parlez moi
je vais vous dire pourquoi je voulais
c'est que ayant baroud et j'ai
assisté mais quand je dis j'ai assisté
c'est que j'étais à 500 mètres d'une
révolte au mexique dans les années 80 et
une à
côté de cleveland par deux voire
d'abandon au siège de de kodak côté de
roc chester quand
vous avez la garde nationale
c'est le même nombre les deux dans les
pays que les tirs on entend que c'est à
tirs réels là
vous avez vous
avez je suis pas un militaire dans la
main et vous avez un vrai sentiment de
panique un vrai sentiment panique parce
que vous sentez que ça y est c'est parti
moi je veux dire il n'y a plus plus rien
plus rien ne peut être rattrapé or je
sais simplement que si les j'utilise
beaucoup le terme de portance humaine
faite
de l'avion donc vous savez que bon vous
me l'avez dit tout à l'heure en me
disant j'aime bien l'avion et vous
m'avez parlé de guéret et
la baston
l'instant vous venez de me dire que
l'aérodrome j'aime orient les avions à
part d'enfants et bien si j'ai voyagé va
si vous regardez les avions vous avez
certainement des copains ou des copines
à l'aéro à l'aérogare et y en a un qui
m'a fait pilotée alors je sais pas
piloter un petit jodel je crois que ça
s'appelle comme ça je vous donne un
tuyau de haydn et qui m'a dit écoute
pendant tu pilotes c'est attention parce
que tu as tu vois là il ya un trait
rouge il faut pas que tu dépasses le
trait rouge pourquoi il m'a dit pas ce
que tu veux tu perds la portance de
l'avion jia soir qui suis je sauf
sauf à faire de l'acrobatie y est j'ai
retenu ce terme de portance et le terme
de portance humaine je
me la tribu et je crois que si on joue
malheureusement avec la portance humaine
là
on risque le risque de payer en
continuant à avoir une politique
malthusienne je dis ça pour faire mal à
mon
écosystèmes une politique malthusienne
de dépenser de plus en plus pour obtenir
de moins en moins de richesse ça
peut pas durer alors quelles sont les
solutions parce que là on est quand même
parti dans un système qui a une inertie
phénoménal belhamel avec surtout une
inertie psychologique phénoménal à la
limite pathologique pour certains les
partis politiques on va même à
l'international sont sous l'eau même
régime de se faire financer par des
banquiers qui détiennent la dette oui
allez vous effectuer par un ingénieur du
son qui détiennent
la dette des partis politiques pour la
plupart tous endettés donc
ils sont tenus en laisse donc quelles
sont les solutions pour vaincre
l'inertie de ce système qui est
titanesque faire
changer les esprits et qui est un
changement de phase en
cause des lunettes roses on met tout le
monde sous sédatifs on l'aimé tout sous
anxiolytiques on met un dictateur en
place ont fait qu'on réclame un kaiser
on s'assoit tous autour du feu réfléchis
dans un climat jeunes comme moi
commencent par boire un coup oui mais ça
c'est moi je reconnais le creusot et
on est dans un climat géopolitique de
guerre économique phénoménale les
chinois nous en veulent tellement depuis
la guerre de l'opium qui sont pas prêts
de lâcher le morceau les américains sont
partis un petit peu dans une attitude de
gendarme du monde toxicomanes et
relançant leur croissance par des
guerres et j'en passe et des meilleurs
donc nous français quel est notre rôle à
jouer on fait comme le coach monte à 6
heures du matin oddo tas de fumier et
ont fait cocorico pour réveiller le
mandé ans pour un coup de fusil mais au
moins on sera debout sur nos deux jambes
où on attend gentiment que sa star
et puis on descend gentiment la descente
aux enfers on fait quoi alors la
vie hawtin non non
parce que qu'il
y ait des hommes providentiels qui
apparaissent je pense qu'il ya toujours
il ya toujours dans ces moments là enfin
en fait les hommes providentiels se
nourrissent quelque part de ces moments
de chahut donc je sais pas peut-être que
c'est
joli ce moment du chahut oui de chaos
c'était beau c'était pour éviter le mot
cahour mais on peut comprendre qu'un
chat tu as vraiment on peut parler de
chaos on peut parler de cas alors qu'à
ou pourquoi régime hyper inflationniste
pénurie
tensions
géopolitiques guerre ah non mais je veux
jouer je vais faire image mais je peux
vous faire le le jeu peut vous faire
malheureusement le scénario le plus le
plus cataclysmique qui soit c'est
effectivement un
effondrement monétaire financier bien
au-delà de ce que l'on avait connue
doublé
d'émeutes qui se transforment en guerre
civile
donc arrivé je suis très très inquiet de
la montée des populismes sur terre enfin
je veux dire c'est s'effrayant ce qui
est en train de se passer et
qui se nourrissent et qui se nourrissent
du fait que nous
sommes une énorme machine à créer des
frustrés puisque vous avez un discours
qui est de 10 j'en
veux sur 2,3 points à notre président
bien
aimé de la république vaincrons vous
avez voté macron oui vous pouvez bien
les coups y menant non
parce que je veux dire j'étais
jeune j'ai déjeuné à côté de 2,2 de
madame le pen elle elle est drôle et les
rigolades canton se quand on se battait
sur la boîte de cornichons par rapport à
notre pot-au-feu on sent que on sent
qu'elles lâchent pas le morceau donc
mais le seul problème c'est que avant
que des gens je veux dire raisonnable ne
la rejoigne pour aider à gérer un pays
comme le nôtre il va falloir un certain
temps mais qui va rejoindre non mais
justement aujourd'hui personne
aujourd'hui personne alors
le
scénario catastrophe c'est effectivement
faillite monétaire
liquéfaction des sols liquéfaction du
système émeutes guerres civiles et comme
à ce moment là la guerre civile fait que
l'on va détester non pas soi même mais
le voisin d'à côté le voit aussi des
basanés surtout si les bases à neige il
est gay attitude c'est plus facile mais
c'est tellement facile mais c'est elle
qui sont les responsables les vrais
responsables alors je
veux pas faire plaisir à votre auditoire
pas ce que je vais dire que nous sommes
tous responsables
par notre misérabilisme de l'impuissance
par notre subornation accepté par quoi
oui par notre servitude volontaire
dangereux de la boétie pourquoi mais
comment se fait-il que la
plus démunie de mes nièces empile
empiler les
tee-shirts ça n'a pas de sens alors
qu'elle même se prétend économat chain
etc enfin je veux dire on est dans cette
logique
je
crois que c'est ford qui disait que
l'argent est un excitant et est une
source de plaisir je je je le concède
bien volontiers donc effectivement étant
donné qu'on a créé des conditions d'un
festivus festivus puisque je le cite les
merveilleux cette phrase l'homme qui
festive de festivent essais mais
parce qu'on lui a donné les moyens la
génération de mon père mon grand père
moyens grands pères ont généré c'est à
dire que tout ce qui faisait
l'obligation
pour un être humain de se battre pour
son existence il
là où pire il a le sentiment que la
collectivité va lui donner pour
l'éternité donc il aura droit à son
agglo donc il aura droit à sa pizza il
aura droit à ces mètres carrés il aura
droit à de l'eau chaude il aura droit à
des soins dessin gratuit etc et
il s'aperçoit alors quand il vient de
l'extérieur il s'aperçoit que
l'arrière-cour de du supermarché côté
poubelle c'est pas du tout ça donc
effectivement quand il peut envoyer un
pain sur quelqu'un il envoie ce qu'il
est frustré et en intérieur on promet un
enrichissement à tout le monde qui ne
sera plus le cas puisque comme nous
sommes dans un processus de récession
cacher
ça veut dire que la taille réelle du
gâteau dit vu donc
quand je me suis gêné j'ai eu des
négociations avec la cgt il ya 40 ans
pour certains de mes clients etc et on
avait on avait la possibilité
parce qu'il y avait cette croissance
réelle est
donc effectivement les syndicats ont
beau jeu de dire mais c'est nous qui
avons tiré la croissance non il y avait
une croissance et vous avez aidé à mieux
la répartir en rentrant dans une dans
une lutte capital travail mais
aujourd'hui il faut que et le capital et
le travail accepte
de considérer qu'il ya régression et
c'est là on va être la zone franche donc
je vais répondre maintenant à votre
question après cette
petite mise au point qui
est majeure la
première chose c'est
l'acceptation
de la dîme de la situation accepte
d'être malade vraiment on prend
conscience mais c'est évident mais c'est
évident et j'ai eu deux cas de figure
que je peux citer celui de quelqu'un
dans ma famille gravement malade qui a
refusé en disant mais non mais non c'est
une connerie et cetera nom et
l'autre cas d'un oncle du ch'nord et
cetera il passe sa coronographie à 10
heures qui lui dit c'est bouché mais il
appelle sa femme et un tu m'amènes en
pyjama je vais à l'hôpital il a même pas
hésité une seconde quand
le type première
chose le parallèle être admettre ah oui
mais attendez c'est
le processus y admet claude elly quand
tous d'accord sa part chose la deuxième
c'est
que dans ce processus d'admettre vous
aidiez je vous remercie de ce que vous
faites
ce que vous y contribuez
c'est que on développe ce que j'appelle
mois l'optimisme de combat et pas
l'optimisme crédules arrêtons
la crédulité arrêtons de croire ce qui
nous donne l'eau tiède dont on a envie
déconstruit demandé au jour c'est à dire
prendre conscience free mais c'est un
choc émotionnel pour certains toutes ces
personnes koné qui acceptent de jouer
souvent les règles du jeu de payer leurs
impôts dans mêlant enfants l'école de
bien les éduque qui de il se rendre
compte du joueur humain qu'il y avait
une eau pure classe qui s'est bien gavé
parce que l'été dans une dans une dans
un climat propice et que du jour au
lendemain le rêve peut se terminer alors
je
maintiens d'être libéral et capitaliste
pourquoi parce que vous êtes view parce
que je suis hyper concret il m'arrive
d'être peut-être utopiste parce que je
pense qu'il ya des solutions mais vous
ne trouverez pas un mec plus pragmatique
que moi par rapport à des problèmes d'où
vient ce pragmatisme il vient du fait
que naturellement quand il ya un
problème si
un jour certains de mes associés me
regardent ils vont se marrer je suis
depuis 40 ans le spécialiste des mandats
compliqué mais
c'est pas parce que j'aime la complexité
par elle même c'est pas parce que j'aime
me faire mal à la tête c'est que soit
vous faites du process vous venez en
tant que plombier il ya la fuite le
machin ou non c'est qu'on regarde le
chemin critique entre une situation est
là où il faut arrive et
si effectivement à mon âge je je je je
revendique une compétence c'est
de faire un diagnostic à l'acide d'une
situation
de regarder le chemin critique qu'il
faut pour atteindre un
socle pour atteindre le bon fond pour
éviter la liquéfaction des sols dans
ce processus première étape il faut
admettre le deuxième c'est qu'il faut
accepter que l'optimisme ne soit pas de
se dire demain sera aussi bien qu'ils
aient non demain sera moins bien qu'il
ait effectivement
on peut pleurer à ce moment là où se
dire dans le fond j'ai encore la force
j'ai encore l'énergie j'ai encore des
systèmes de sécurité sociale enfin bref
j'ai encore des harnais qui me
permettent d'aborder la situation de
façon sereine
et
à partir de là il ya un mot clé est là
encore mais mais mais mais patrons vont
l'aimer c'est passé de cette logique de
croissance à une logique de pérennité à
dire des croissances à je déteste ce mot
pour qu'on puisse dire récession alors
pourquoi je pourquoi je parle sont
négatives alors oui je parle de boues de
fosses croissance croissance alors
pourquoi pourquoi je parle je le jeu
n'utilise jamais le terme de
décroissance pour
une raison simple c'est que la
décroissance est éteint de mon point de
vue est un état d'esprit qui
est effectivement
de
de son taux régulier dans la régression
non
attendez vous allez me dire que c'est
exactement ce à quoi je vais arriver
mais
la connotation comme
quoi la perception joue parfois plus que
la réalité la perception que j'ai des
partisans des partisans de la
décroissance
j'aime pas leur discours c'est quoi leur
discours leur discours c'est vous faites
pas me fait pas le résumé de ces défis
avec des cheveux longs avec des
dreadlocks où les bras ils sentent
mauvais non c'est un peu le faire alors
ça c'est bien ça je vais pas je vais pas
osé non non non non vous le pensez non
non pas du tout pas du tout non je pense
je pense que c'est une inversion du
progrès vous
vous trouvez pas et s'ils décident eux
de
vous mettre à leur place vous
êtes vieux vous avez eu les trente
glorieuses avait connu des époques sans
le sida c'était super sympa le
lsd et j'en passe et des meilleurs vous
avez eu mireille mathieu et j'en passe
mais maintenant votre génération propose
à notre génération du
sang et des larmes c'est pas ça le
progrès pour le progrès c'est peut-être
faire attention à son prochain ce temps
de l'âme ralentir
je vais et quand on dit un financier
ralenti il a tout de suite des boutons
parce que le financier comme le
politique aime faire que de la cavalerie
de la cavalerie verbal la limite de la
lorie et le financier quand on lui dit
de ralentir il sait que si elle ralentit
il se casse la gueule donc
le décroissant il aime prendre un
nouveau bonheur que peut-être votre
génération oubliée alors d'abord je
conteste le je conteste formellement le
qualificatif de vieux parce que parce
que à
97 ans ma mère la creusoise prenait son
billet pour faire le tour des états-unis
en en
engrais en bus d'accord et comme le
chauffeur refuse et qu'elles montrent
une bouteille de pinard elle s'est
arrêtée pour prendre une bouteille de
coca dans lequel elle mettait du du
muscadet enfin l'équivalent américain et
pour pouvoir picoler tranquille c'était
elle est morte quatre ans plus tard mais
enfin je veux dire je
me sens mais pas du tout du tout du tout
c'est
pas une blague ce que je vous dis est
une réalité mais
par contre je sais que ce que je dis
n'est
pas plaisant parce que vous n'allez pas
jusqu'au bout alors effectivement je dis
que on peut passer d'un staccato un
adagio sublime où
on peut passer on peut passer du hard
rock à
dieu a dû à du jazz funky tout
à fait tout à fait sympa hein je vous
dis enfin on peut trouver on peut
trouver l'idée
d'ailleurs il ya de la musique moderne
que je trouve il ya même du rap que je
trouve tout à fait tout à fait agréable
lequel vous êtes piégés parce que les
noms les normes trop totalement inconnu
mais m je peux pas vous dire je t aime
se laisser dévorer ministère mais non
mais je veux dire c'est le nom c'est du
rap anglo saxons à sur un rythme assez
lent enfin je veux dire volontiers demi
c'est possible donc
on
peut on peut ralentir la machine
le seul problème on peut on peut la
ralentir comment donc
je pars du principe qu'il nous faut à
peu près trois quatre cinq ans de
multiplication des missions comme celle
de ce soir pour que petit à petit la
nomenclature à française et ça j'y crois
ça je crois que si mon père avait choisi
la france c'est parce qu'il considérait
que c'était le pays des libertés et qu'
il peut y avoir en france contrairement
aux anglo saxons il peut y avoir en
france
une pensée d'adaptation
[Musique]
de notre système à un mode qui
est en fait celui de la décroissance
puisque quand je parle de récession nous
sommes en décroissance le seul problème
c'est que comme on ne veut pas
l'admettre on
pousse les feux là où ça ne devrait pas
c'est à dire sur la partie financière et
on casse de l'homme entre-temps premier
tempo donc on a nommé le deuxième tempo
il faut que souvenez vous de mes trois
syllabes il faut que le troisième
cylindres perde de son allez je vais
vous faire plaisir de son arrogance
naturelle pour mega lugano 6 mai mais
que mais qui va de pair mais attendez
quand vous êtes quand vous êtes dans une
des tours de downton manhattan au 43e
étage et en dé l'appeler bonpain grille
où attendait et que sur un tableur excel
je vire des milliards d'une partie du
monde à une eau et que en l'espace d'une
fraction ces
mêmes c'est une vraie fraction 7 au
millième de seconde
j'ai pu générer de
quoi faire le bonheur de nous tous dans
cette pièce pour l'éternité vous avez un
sentiment de puissance tadamer 1 c'est
quoi le bonheur le bonheur c'est de
pouvoir alors il ya eu plein de
définition mais je les ai pas en mémoire
on y en a une qui me va très bien de
churchill c'est la possibilité d'avoir
assez d'argent pour voyager sans rien
c'est
à dire en fait d'être totalement
autonome et libre
le
bonheur moi j'ai connu des garçons qui
effectivement dans le monde ouvrier j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup parlé pendant
très longtemps j'ai vécu j'ai dormi j'ai
bouffé avec le monde ouvrier dans les
années fin des années 70 80 le sam
suffit vous savez le pavillon dans
la banlieue sud de paris oui c'était le
rêve de sa vie c'était d'avoir un toit
je crois qu'effectivement avoir
la possibilité de
savoir où et comment on est à l'abri de
la plus haute oui c'est un des premiers
éléments de du bonheur le bonheur c'est
d'abord c'est de réduire les souffrances
donc ça ça touche à la santé et au
bien-être c'est
de pouvoir se nourrir convenablement
c'est de pouvoir circuler librement à
nos moutons donc notre intelligentsia
franco française capable de faire le coq
ou de son tas de fumier 6h du matin
c'est pas encore une façon d'être de
chausser ses lunettes roses sans vouloir
à la 70 sans vouloir accepter que notre
intelligentsia est totalement mondialisé
sous influence extérieure et que ce que
vous appelez l'essence même du français
s'est diluée dans un yaourt insipide
et bref relative vrai mais justement
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'est ce que nous
allons pouvoir faire il
faut donc il faut d'abord il
faut un contre-pouvoir il
faut un contre pouvoir au silo finances
marche
pas par le glass steagall act la
séparation des banques de détail et
banque d'affaires ça marche pas les
pseudos régulation bancaire ça marche
pas les fous protocole balle un bal de
bâle iii ces histoires de fer rigolo
quand les gens sont inquiets on leur dit
vous inquiétez pas le système financier
stable et la signature française vaut de
l'or nous avons créé le fonds de
garantie des dépôts bancaires
quand on aura fait remarquer qu'ils
n'étaient pas capables de garantir les
comptes bancaires ils ont sorti encore
une nouvelle phrase vous inquiétez pas
on sera capable de faire un effet de
levier sur les marchés c'est
du bullshit toussaint allez
je vais je vais répondre dans dix ans
comme cela le vieux c'est vous c'est moi
nous rayonnons alors
ma grand-mère à quel point déjà 9 ans et
le talent y est c'est la fête des grands
mères dimanche et ma grand mère a
toujours gérer ses finances d'une façon
très rigoriste est vraiment très carrie
parce que les dettes ont préféré serrer
la ceinture mais nous a jamais il a subi
ce congrès c'est un bon qui je vais
attendre il faut absolument que je
réponde il faut absolument j'aurais
prône à 100 de
deux choses l'une soit dans les années
qui viennent mais très proche et c'est
là où il faut je répète que des
émissions comme la vôtre soit diffusé
les reprises de deux choses l'une soit
ce
dont vous parlez c'est à dire qu'ils
payent leurs impôts qui éduquent leurs
enfants etc acquiert
un d'abord un doute puis admettent il
m'a fallu huit ans mais a fallu vingt
ans de recherches et 8 ans pour admettre
qu'il n'y avait pas de croissance
naturelle huit ans alors je suis un
homme du métier d'accord mais c'est
normal comment ça prouve bien tout le
monde put faire vous kir absolument mais
alors là tout le monde il
faut surtout de la ténacité de la
psychologie et puis à prendre une
trousse à outils et la maîtrise pourquoi
parce qu'effectivement et en étant né
dans cet univers de croissance a priori
perpétuelle envisagée
puis admettre que cette croissance
n'existe plus et la première phase comme
sortir les gens d'une secte oui oui oui
absolument ça correspond à ça parce
qu'on on est complètement c'est addictif
enfin je veux dire c'est complètement
addictif ce processus or deux choses
l'une soit je reprends ce père de
famille frank familles françaises
parfaite avec son son plan des pales son
banquier qui lui dit tu y as tu devrais
jouer là-dessus et c'est être bien soit
il a acquis cette intime conviction que
ce discours de croissance éternelle est
à l'heure 1-1
quand il va entendre a priori les
candidats qui vont touche lui promettent
que la croissance va va permettre de
payer la dette il devrait dire mais
attendez vous pouvez expliquer
réellement comment vous allez faire plus
bruno le maire est sûrement un type très
bien mais j'aimerais être confronté à
lui 30 secteur par secteur et lui dire
où vas-tu trouver de la croissance dans
ce secteur je veux faire de cet ordre
donc soit vous avez encore la conviction
qui est de la croissance soit vous ne
l'avez pas on va partir de ces deux
hypothèses si
vous êtes convaincu qu'il ya de la
croissance ma
proposition ne
peut pas marche pourquoi parce
que vous allez exiger de
votre gérant d'epargne vous allez exiger
de votre employeur vous allez exiger de
tout le monde de
donner toujours davantage ces problèmes
dès fois activistes en ce moment contre
danone c'est un scandale pour une fois
que nous avons une france en france une
grande entreprise mondialement connus
sont pas en suisse non c'est mais ce
n'est pas son père si nous tombons
d'accord
et qui a une gestion effectivement on va
dire humaniste bon les activistes dit il
faut il faut y aller tu ne gagnes pas
assez d'argent pourquoi les activistes
ce qu'on appelle les fonds activiste
donc on a si
on considère qu'il y a malgré ce que
raphaël rossello ce que les
gens que vous invitez et sur d'autres
d'autres plateaux 10 mais non mais non
c'est pas vrai il n'y a pas de
croissance il ya deux là il ya de la
décroissance où il ya de la régression
si vous refusez ça demain vous allez
demander toujours plus mécaniquement
si par contre nous arrivons est ce pour
ça que je pense qu'il ya une fenêtre de
tir de 3 5 ans si nous arrivons à créer
un doute légitime un
doute légitime dans
voilà
dans dans l'univers parisien de
ceux qui partagent le pouvoir je
leur propose le mot de pérenniser
arrêtez
de chercher toujours plus cherché
à protéger ce que vous avez acquis or
je
pense pouvoir convaincre parce que j'en
ai tout autour de moi moi moi je suis à
la jonction entre le nom de l' épargne
et le monde des entrepreneurs je traduis
le discours des uns pour les autres et
je trouve le point d'équilibré entre les
deux rues si effectivement les
les souscripteurs de l'epargne disent à
leur épargne en savent et ils sont
maintenant nombreux à considérer que la
que la croissance est artificielle qu'il
n'ya plus que de l'adn machin etc les
gérants vont s'adapter parce que c'est
des types intelligents et vous dira
d'accord d'accord alors vous avez soit
la possibilité que
je vous propose d'aller sur les produits
actions machin truc pour augmenter votre
patrimoine soit vous n'y croyez pas et
je vous propose de pérenniser ah bon et
on va faire comment ah ben pour
pérenniser
vous avez des fonds qui vont vous donner
du 2% du 1% mais
qui vont permettre à des milliers
d'emplois d'être stabilisé et
parmi mes clients j'ai j'ai cette
problématique et j'en citerai pas le nom
parce que je ne suis pas autorisé
entreprise de mécanique
huit entreprises en france 2
en dehors de france avec
les intérimaires en ce qu'on appelle en
temps plein emploi en emplois temps
plein 1600
personnes 1700 personnes dans
l'industrie c'est énorme parce que si
vous multipliez par tous les gens qui
dépendent ça fait ça fait des milliers
de gens qui dépendent de cet
entrepreneur
quelles sont les exigences des fonds que
je lui trouve dans les mécaniques monga
bruxelles nous dit il faut il faut qu'il
dégage du 10% jamais
mais jamais dans ces métiers là on ne
peut dégager plus de 4
à 5% alors qu'est ce qui se passe quand
je vais voir l'état merci merci me dit
ah non non non on peut pas lui prêter en
dessous du taux de 10 je dirais qu'à
turin mais pas de beaucoup parce que
bruxelles va nous retoqué qui
attendez attendez c'est
une entreprise il ya peut-être de vingt
mille personnes en france qui dépend de
ceux de cette usine va de ses usines ah
oui mais c'est comme ça bon
d'accord et si je me tourne alors il ya
des fonds impacts locaux etc mais ils
n'ont pas les moyens parce que pour
produire il fait 300 350 millions de
chiffre d'affaires beaucoup oui
il faut des ateliers avec des usines
avec des matériels d'usinage et c'est
donc
il faut du capital à dimension de ce
roman
hebbadj
est pas donc appel
solennel de raphaël rossello ce soir si
on sait que view aidez
moi aidez moi aidez nous à trouver des
moyens à trouver des moyens financiers
en harmonie avec l'économie réelle alors
je joue mais sur un deuxième cas de
figure imaginez-vous je dois payer les
retraites des fonctionnaires américains
qui font que de grandir et de grossir et
de se multiplier imaginez vous que je
suis en train de me rendre compte que
les rendements que j'ai promis bon je
peux peut-être à vous et je vais pas
pouvoir les tenir mais la stabilité dont
modèle ne va plus pouvoir être assuré je
vous vois hocher la tête parce qu'il ya
des gens qui nous ont qu'ils écoutent
aussi en podcast donc le modèle ne va
plus pouvoir être assurés mais des fonds
de pension américains dans ce cas de
figure journal long comme le bras je
reconnais bah ouais donc qu'est ce qui
va se passer ces gens ils vont pousser
pour éviter votre modèle parce que s'il
accepte votre modèle il se coupe les
bras ils se coupent les deux jambes et
puis et puis après ils les retraités
vont aller les attrapés pour attendait
pourquoi pourquoi je suis optimiste
soit
et si je viens ce soir c'est parce que
je suis porteur de 7 à petit nous invite
idée en soi
mais
pour accepter ce pour rentrer dans cette
phase de l'optimisme vrai pas
du bullshit du vrai il faut admettre
qu'il n'y a plus de croissance c'est à
dire que le socle de nos existences
depuis 50 ans n'existe
plus donc monsieur bruno le maire ne me
dites pas que là que là que la dette va
être remboursée par la croissance il n'y
en aura pas
je pense que si demain la croix le monde
teintés charlie
hebdo et cetera pilonnent en disant il
doit y avoir un fond de vérité parce
qu'il ya des chiffres parce qu'il ya des
données il ya des faits avérés et c est
ce qu on peut ouvrir le chantier
ce sont mes 3 5 ans de considérer qu'il
n'y a plus de croissance non
mais attendez mais pourquoi parce que si
on ne rentre pas dans cette logique là
c'est
le collapse c'est
cesser les guerres c'est le sens c'est
tout ce que je ne veux pas connaître
et surtout je ne veux pas que tous les
jeunes qui m'entourent puisse connaître
alors je vous coupe parce que l'on
pourrait on pourrait disserter sur ce
sujet encore très longtemps donc vous
parler de sang alors je connais un deal
ganache qui dit quand le sang commence à
couler dans les rues il est temps
d'investir dans la pierre là
il ya la communauté qui nous demandent
est-ce que vous avez vous vous si vous
deviez stocker votre votre épargne vos
actifs votre patrimoine ou votre
richesse n'est pas sûr
qu'elle sur quels types d' actifs les
moins risqués alors on n'est pas en
train de donner des conseils
d'investissement bien entendu et non
mais je vais vous dire at il personne à
titre perso j'ai quoi j'ai pu
vider
bitcoin pourront
pas garder cette question juste après
j'ai
cette chance j'ai cette chance
extraordinaire d'être un français vivant
à paris dans un appartement qui
m'appartient qui est totalement payés
qui
mignon qui part inquiet pas qui est
petit mais qui est très très très très
mignon places plein plein sud c est une
résidence secondaire dans
le pays basque fini terminé payer j'ai
des assurances vie dont je pense qu'elle
risque de se faire bigné à un moment ou
un autre mais qui aujourd'hui me
permettent en complément de mes revenus
puisque je continue d'être conseil je
vieillis avec mon fonds de commerce qui
me permette effectivement de dire que je
devrais a priori jusqu'à là bas être
capable de garder ces deux éléments je
fais donc partie des ddd
rare pour
le reste oui j'ai investi dans des
assurances vie parce que c'était parce
que c'était à la mode parce que enfin
loyers impayés il y avait toutes les
raisons mais quand je vois que mon
assurance vie en euros puisque j'ai pas
voulu avoir de risque me dégage encore
je crois que c'est 2% ou 1,8 je me
demande comment est ce qu'ils arrivent à
faire avec des avec des taux d'intérêt
de base qui sont à zéro donc ça veut
dire que les gérants dope un petit peu
avec de l'immobilier locatif avec on
joue un petit peu sur les deux vis enfin
bref il faut ils font leur job qu'est
que je ne connais pas je ne sais pas
gérer et c'est pour ça que suis très
content de l'art de l'ordre
pour
le reste il
n'y a pas de yap libre je dirais il n'y
a pas de martingale c'est si
j'avais pu j'aurais eu peut-être
quelques studios à pouvoir louer mais en
sachant tous les emmerdements des
propriétaires adhérents je m'aperçois
que ceux qui ont une grande et à axa peu
marchands de de saint jean de luz qui
avaient des boutiques ses boutiques
payent pas leur loyer donc il y passe en
bail précaire enfin bref 16 c'est
la cata donc il n'ya pas de comment
dirais-je il
n'y a pas de revenus miracle il y a
simplement le fait que je dis regardez
comment vous pouvez pérenniser votre
patrimoine se faire tondre éviter de se
faire tondre bon donc le gouvernement
vous dis que je crois que l'assurance et
de jeu puis cissé sans milou 75000 euros
26 et sa wii garde emmanuel dupuis
pousse alors c'est du pipeau si ce n'est
que si on envisage par le bain de sang
puisque
c'est ce que je veux éviter d'accord on
doit pouvoir faire en sorte que
l'économie française perdure
un
rythme plus lent je
vous coûte infiniment vous avez vous
coupez combien combien de % de la
population française gagne autour du
smic abbas
est pourtant
un nouveau bail soit 2 81% combien de
personne a sur son compte en banque plus
de 72000 aux 10
à tours 20 % maximum 15%
je vous laisse continuer ouais
absolument
donc c'est de pérenniser ce alors
pourquoi j'utilise ce mot c'est parce
que je fais un petit bonjour aux patrons
de la mayenne que j'accompagne mon le
hasard fait que je vois je après
strasbourg toulouse j'ai quelques
clients dans ce beau département et ils
ont ils ont toujours eu ce mot
pérenniser ce que c'est un pays agricole
sa et c'est ce que je propose c'est
effectivement de pérenniser nos acquis
or si nous ne rentrons pas dans le piège
malthusien d'augmenter
la dette de
façon disproportionnée par rapport aux
résultats que l'on espère ont
réduit le montant de l'endettement qui
nous appauvrit mécaniquement pour
revenir simplement à la pérennisation de
nos actifs car
un actif
c'est un actif net et je m'adresse à
tous ceux qui ont acheté leur
appartement ou leur maison elle vaut
deux cent mille euros qu'ils ont prises
150000 euros de crédits leur actif n'est
pas de 200 mille îles et de 50000
d'accord
donc pour
je
dirais pérenniser
l'actif dette il faut arrêter
d'augmenter la dette pour un rendement
de croissance qu'il y ait des croissants
il est là le piège mais il est fou ce
piège il est dément et là par contre
vous me parlez de mon univers mais quand
j'en parle il
me regarde on est maintenant on te
connaît depuis dix quinze vingt ans
était en gros t'es un mec sérieux qu'est
ce que tu viens de raconter et
quant à ce moment là je rentre dans le
détail des chiffres il se lève il parle
marais mais parce que mais parce que
pourquoi ça me fait marrer mais parce
qu'ils sont dans cette logique de ce dit
c'est
pas vrai ils sont dans le déni et
mais ça je peux le comprendre alors
juste on va changer de sujet on va
parler des bitcoins juste pour
l'immobilier j'ai un copain qui est
grand grand grand grand banquier il m'a
dit faites attention parce que en temps
de crise le premier actif qui est axé
c'est celui que tu peux pas bouger c'est
à dire l'immobilier donc l'état qui va
chercher de l'argent il va taxer tous
les propriétaires y compris des gens qui
ont acheté une petite maison à 150
millions dans le fin fond de la mayenne
et c'est là où ils font alors que des
questions web etc ok juste juste et
l'injuste arbres comme game comme gaël
giraud le disait sur ce plateau c'est
que pourquoi est-ce qu'on veut pourquoi
ce que tout le monde veut passer à de
l'argent électronique c'est devant les
raser plus rapidement mais exactement et
revenons à nos moutons on parlera de la
taxe tobin peut-être milliers le nickel
un rafale non mais je sais ça barde par
miguel les
bitcoins monsieur de banquiers les
crypto monnaie vous
étouffez pas je fais pas une bille
cherche le
bitcoin c'est
à billets de monopoly pourquoi bas
qui n'est pas détenu dans la main des
banques centrales c'est peut-être sa
principale qualité dont l'âme est temps
d'aller faire que le politique ne peut
pas jouer dessus il peut l'interdire
christine
lagarde pas ce qui lui arrive de dire
des choses tout à fait sensée a dit ce
n'est pas une menace et un actif et
cet actif est malheureusement utilisé
comme monnaie pour des tractations
douteuses
parce que parce qu'on sait pas juste
donc ya pas de n'y a pas de traçabilité
le cash comme le cash absolue le
bitcoin jeu
je vais vous répondre par une anecdote
vécue sur madison dont les années 80 18
99 puisque j'allais aux états unis au
moins cinq fois par an voire notre
bureau américain qui qui aimait beaucoup
toutes les pme que j'emmenais que
que que j'en ai sur le marché et
quand je lui demande à mon cabas arabe
mais tu
peux m'expliquer ce qui se passe médias
mais je vais te raconter l'anecdote delà
du petit char de la riche héritière qui
se trouvent toujours sur madison mais
beaucoup plus haut en face en
pratiquement en face du metropolitan
museum ou
que sais quoi on dresse ici si elle
avait un adorable petit chat et sa
voisine qui avait le même hôtel
particulier lui dira mais je voudrais
absolument acheter ton petit chat est ce
que tu me levant oui oui à
combien 20 millions $ et
1000 et au delà pour un petit chat non
mais tu peux tu plaisantes écoute tu me
demandes d'acheter mon petit chat je te
vends mon petit chat 20 millions de là
je
dis oui et alors eh bien là vendu son
petit chat et
elle a encaissé 20 millions de dollars
ah non non non non non non non non elle
a reçu deux petits chiens à 10 millions
de dollars chaque l'a vécu
mon ami vécu c'est
à dire que quand je créé ex nihilo une
valeur car
le bitcoin ce pas parce que yabs il ya
un courant électrique qui vient nourrir
un algorithme s'est créé ex nihilo dudu
du cyberespace ok si
j'ai un conte qui vient l'acheter en
face de moi je lui donne une valeur et
je vais vous dire pourquoi je me méfie
terriblement de ça c'est que j'ai eu la
chance il est possible qu'il fasse
partie d'ailleurs de vous de vos
auditeurs d'introduire
en bourse une
affaire qui s'appelait artprice
a lyon allure oui un ancien hacker
d'accord
et
alors
que tout le monde lui faisait la cour
pour introduire sa société votre
serviteur l'a accompagné sur les fonts
baptismaux du marché financier pages et
il m'a expliqué dans la ferme du chaos
la
demeure c'est la demeure j'aurai que
c'était la demeure du chaos à la demeure
du chaos il
m'a expliqué un petit peu comment le
marché de l'art avant
que je ne me tourner vers les métiers de
l'argent je voulais être un juriste
dollar ok j'étais à l'école du louvre et
j'avais eu des amitiés avec un certain
nombre d'experts et qui m'avait raconté
des histoires merveilleuses
sur la problématique de la valeur de l'
expertise en
fait en fait ce à quoi nous assistons
aujourd'hui c'est un gigantesque marché
de l'art contemporain je dis pas l'art
moderne et l'art contemporain or l'art
contemporain consiste à raconter une
storytelling comme on dit une une
histoire bon
varois cato inc tous ensemble ce soit on
va sans raconter une et comme vous avez
une belle audience voilà on va prendre
une fois un fauteuil on va considérer
que georges pompidou avait ce fauteuil
dans son dans son bureau à l'elysée donc
on va raconter tout ce qui s'est passé
sur ce fauteuil on va on va faire un
joli petit truc on va le mettre chez
sotheby's mais chez sotheby's ils vont
pas le prendre je vous dire non ça c'est
un homme de bureau et c est donc à ce
moment là eh ben on va tous ensemble
avec notre camionnette de de brocanteurs
on va faire des petites salles de vente
au
fin fond du jallet ou du piémont où de
la castille et c'est la seule chose
qu'on veut c'est une trace écrite que
le fauteuil gelé mis à vendre 50 euros
et qu'il est passé à 100 puis 100 à 200
puis 200 à 400 puis 400 à 500 talata
lala et j'arrive et on se levant entre
nous bien sûr et j'arrive au moment où
ça vaut 100 mille dollars et
la femme j'ai tous les grands champs
tous les grands marchands d'art qui
ont des capteurs partout sur quels sont
les objets d'art contemporain qui ont eu
la croissance de la valeur la plus
fulgurante possible et
là on change d'un coefficient 10 ou 100
c'est que le même fauteuil va passer de
100 mille à un million de la millions à
10 millions vous croyez que jeudi des
chiffres complètement fou non non non
non vous avez eue dans l'une des
dernières ventes un requin coupé en
trois morceaux dans
trois aquariums qui
s'est vendu 15 millions de dollars il
y avait pour 3000 balle d'aquarium et il
y avait pour 1500 balle d'une séance de
chasse en floride de pêche aux requins
prix de revient 5000 ok rien prix de
vente 15 millions je crée 14
millions et 1,2 valeur c'est pas une
façon de sauvegarder son pouvoir d'achat
en investissant noms de l'art ne
faisons plus confiance dans l'est
certains actifs on
vient se réfugier sur l'art et au monde
ce bullshit storytelling pour alors moi
je alors
je reprends le terme de dieu pour moi un
objet a de la valeur s'il a été
travaillée
elle opératif je vais je vais lire lire
un commentaire d'internet qui d'ailleurs
une question de loose il
parle de banquiers hors sol qui ne
voient pas l'absence de croissance mais
est ce qu'ils réalisent que parler de
pérennisation des actifs pour 90 % de la
population ça n'a aucun sens ah non non
non oh là là oh là là parce que non mais
je alors un jeu je comprends la question
je comprends la question étant
donné qu effectivement il a raison pour
95 % de la population qui n'a pas de
patrimoine pérenniser un patrimoine
qu'il n'a pas ne
rien dire attendez
mais si je pérennise les
actifs productifs n'oubliez pas je suis
donc les conseils de pme et deux pays
donc si j'arrive à pérenniser les
outils de production qui
vont permettre à 95% des gens qui n'ont
pas de patrimoine d'avoir
encore une activité qui leur donne une
rémunération digne
c'est
ça que je peux que que que que je vis
pas clair voilà
la communauté d'éclaircir tout ça non
mais je peux je peux recommencer mon
raisonnement c'est que c'est que
effectivement vous avez aujourd'hui je
reprends la notion du bitcoin soit
vous considérez que tesla vos
communautés vous savez vous bullshit et
sur le bitcoin vous n'y connaissez rien
lâcher en train de lire le message ils
sont en train de z'allumés mais
attendez mais j'ai autour de moi des je
sais comment ça fonctionne et j'ai
introduit en bourse dès gens qui
fabriquent des blocs chaîne comment ça
fonctionne vous avez un algorithme qui
clean qui crée une clé en
une fraction de seconde et vous avez de
l'autre côté un autre algorithme quitte
les clés ou avérous plus tôt et ses
cantons marie la bonne clé avec le bon
verrou que l'on crée une transaction
unique
c'est clair ça c'est certain elle est
unique dans toute l'histoire de
l'humanité et qu'on lui donne
l'appellation d'un bitcoin clair
donc sa spécificité c'est d'être unique
mais
ma chaise une fois que j'ai bullshit et
elle devient totalement unique ce
que comment
dirais-je
mais je suis entouré de gens qui qui qui
qui se mordent les doigts parce que je
leur ai dit de ne jamais investir dans
le bitcoin égal et quand ils voient non
mais oui mais attendez c'est les oignons
de tulipes enfin je pense qu'ils le
connaissent tous donc quand au xvième
siècle oignons de tulipes pouvait valoir
aussi cher cac 40 avec quatre chevaux
qui représente le prix de quelque chose
de phénoménal pour l'histoire ça n'était
qu'un oignons de tulipes donc
que l'on créé et que dans un espace que
dans un cyberespace on
donne une valeur de 30 minutes puis
50000 puissant mil etc ok
ça vaut ça vaudra peut-être un million
ça
vaudra peut-être un million mais ça ne
vaut un million que comme pour mes deux
petits chiens ça ne vaut un million que
parce que vous et moi décidons de se
l'acheter à un million il
ya eu il ya eu une expérience qui a été
fait je reviens au marché de l'art
contemporain
où on a fait faire des copies mais
parfaite d'oeuvre qui ont été vendus à
des prix astronomiques pour les mettre
dans des salles de ventes plus petites
où j'ai des brocanteurs et cetera ça
partait même pas au poids du cadre donc
c'est bien c'est bien l'histoire que
l'on raconte
et comme monsieur musk et 1 je
veux dire si les fabuleuses cet homme
c'est le sait le pirate du siècle et
comme tous les pirates il est éminemment
a été dur éminemment
intelligent et donc en donnant je ne
sais plus si c'était un milliard un
milliard et demi de dollars de
bitcoin qu'il a acheté il
concile consolidait et donner un coup de
tampon à la valeur mais
ça la range en tant que propriétaire
à 10 12 15 % je me souviens plus de
tesla qui
est sûr que tu es par rapport à
tout ce que l'on sait de 95% et ne venez
pas me dire que ce chiffre de 95 % et
totalement loufoque
les
katas que j'ai vécu dans les années 2002
2003 2004 était
sur 95% de décote
souvenez-vous d'alcatel cent mille
personnes leader mondial des téléphones
99%
de paume pendant
trois ans avant que ça ne rebelles by 6
99%
de paume donc quand je vous dis que
tesla est sûre que tu es 2 95% c'est pas
un chiffre c'est que cinq ou six pour
cent de 600 millions ça fait 36 millions
ça fait trente six mille 37
c'est la capitalisation boursière d'un
géant automobile qui fait 10 fois plus
de bagnoles dix fois plus rentable et
qui a cent fois plus de brevets que n'en
a t cela on arrive à la fin de notre
interview est-ce que vous avez trois
livres a conseillé à notre communauté
alors
j'ai je peux mettre le mien non sur
sûr j'imagine que c'est sur les thèmes
que je développe aux
livres qui ont marqué votre vie trop
livre sur le thème que vous venez
d'amendé alors alors notre communauté
dit beaucoup il
dévore les livres donc n'hésitez pas
alors il ya un livre qui m'a
profondément
marqué
c'est la beauté sauvera le monde de
dominique breau parce
que je crois qu'effectivement si on ne
sortent pas de jeux
d'hier aigu du du marécage dans lequel
on est on est aujourd'hui il faut
prendre de la hauteur en fin jeudi à il
faut il
y a
je ne sais plus mais c'est passionnant
l'histoire des hasards frères à
gaza la banque lazard qui
est absolument passionnant sur mon show
sur mon univers c'est le
troisième
[Musique]
le
pot pour le troisième je prendrai un
grand classique et
mon
choix irait plus naturellement vers les
essais de montagne est-ce que vous avez
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
oh oui oh oui alors
je
garantis
à tous les jeunes qui nous écoute que
si ils
se mettent en
disposition d'être quelqu'un de fiable
et je vais je vais répondre à ça
quel que soit leur niveau d'éducation de
culture ils auront toujours un
une rémunération qui leur permettra de
vivre dignement et plus et plus qu'est
ce que j'appelle la fiabilité la
fiabilité c'est justement de ne pas
vendre de
fausses promesses tout le temps du genre
je
te rappelle demain il rappelle pas où je
je vais livrer sa où je vais faire ça il
ne le fait pas c'est faire ce qu'on dit
et dire ce qu'on faire et dire ce qu'on
fait
raphaël rossello merci c'est moi qui
vous remercie infiniment
[Musique]